ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ यस या सो
आई थिंक आई एम लाइव गाइस लेट मी
नो लेट मी नो गाइस प्लीज मुझे बताइए जल्दी
से मैं एक बार चैट में देख लेता हूं मेरी
आवाज जा रही है ऑडियो वीडियो सब क्लियर है
गाइस प्लीज प्लीज लेट मी नो जल्दी से बता
दीजिए जल्दी से बता दीजिए सभी लोग वेलकम
एवरी
बडी
ओके सो गाइस एम आई ऑडिबल एंड
विजिबल किसने लाइक नहीं किया अब तक
बिल्कुल सही लाइक लाइक लाइक लाइक कर दो
भाई तो जल्दी से बता दीजिए क्या मेरी आवाज
आपको क्लियर जा रही है क्या ऑडियो वीडियो
सब सही है ओके ओके बढ़िया बढ़िया लेट मी
चेक माय
एक बार मैं खुद भी चेक कर लेता
हूं जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट ओके एवरीथिंग इज फाइन आई थिंक चलो जो
आ रहे हो लाइक ठोकते
[संगीत]
जाओ
ओके यस ओके वेलकम एवरी बडी वेलकम टू द डे
19 क्लास 19 ऑफ आवर फ्री बग बाउंट कोर्स
बाय डि फ्रक्स एंड आज बहुत धमाका करने
वाले हैं लाइव हम लाइव वेबसाइट्स जो है जो
बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स चलाती है उन परे हम
एक्सेसेस फाइंड करने वाले हैं जिसका
ऑटोमेटेड मैनुअल वे देखने वाले हैं एक और
चीज के बारे में मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं
जो एक्सेसेस जब आप फाइंड करते हो तो उस
टाइम आपको उसका ध्यान देना चाहिए वो एक
सिक्योरिटी मेजर है जिसको अगर आप बायपास
कर पाते हैं बाय चांस तो आपके लिए थोड़ा
एक्सेसेस फाइंड करना इजी हो जाता है आज के
टाइम में सारे वेब एप्लीकेशंस उसको
इंप्लीमेंट करके रखते हैं बाय डिफॉल्ट
मोस्टली एंड आपको कुछ डिफरेंट
अप्रोचेबल हैं आगे कैसे हर एक जगह पे
एक्सेसेस आपको मिल सकता है हर एक जगह पे
आपको एक्सस फाइंड करने का मौका मिलेगा एंड
वहां पे आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं राइट तो
चलिए यहां पे सबसे पहले हमारी ये डेनिक्स
साइबर सिक्योरिटी हमारी कंपनी का यह
एंड यहां पे कंपनी के रिलेटेड सारे अपडेट
फ्री कोर्सेस सारी चीजें आपको यहीं पे
मिलने वाली हैं ठीक है उसके बाद हमारी
कंपनी का यह वेबसाइट है इस पे आके आप फर्द
अपडेट्स एंड हमारी प्रोग्रेस को चेक आउट
कर सकते हैं देन यह हमारा
[संगीत]
twittersignin.com
जस्ट वेट फॉर सेकंड एक सेकंड रुक जाइए आप
लोग एक सेकंड जस्ट वेट ठीक है बाकी सब लोग
को आ जाने देते
हैं 34 34 बहुत बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया लेट मी चेक वन थिंग एक बार मुझे
चेक कर लेने दो एक
बार लेट मी चेक लेट मी चेक लेट मी चेक
गाइस यस डीजे चलिए बहुत बढ़िया थैंक यू
डीजे फॉर द सुपर चैट स अगर आपके पास कोई
बुक सजेस्ट करना चाहो पढ़े हो जो बुक
हिंदी में हो और हर स्टूडेंट को पढ़ना
चाहिए हिंदी में हो हिंदी में हो ऐसा मुझे
नहीं पता
यार हिंदी में का तो मुझे नहीं पता बु का
एंड गाइस आज ब बहुत ही कमाल की क्लास होने
वाली है बहुत ही शानदार लाइव हम चीजें
देखने वाले हैं लाइव हम चीजें करने वाले
हैं तो आप लोग बस बने रहिए इस क्लास में
एंड तक और लाइव एक्सस हंटिंग के मजे लीजिए
कैसे एक बग बाउंट की तरह बग बाउटी रिसर्चर
की तरह बग बाउंट हंटर की तरह आप एक्सस के
लिए फाइ जा सकते हैं इसका आप मजा लीजिए
एंड कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मैं आपको
बताऊंगा राइट वो भी आप ध्यान से देखिएगा
मुझे बस कुछ चीजें बस सेट अप कर लेता
हूं
ओके चलिए जस्ट जस्ट वेटिंग
वेटिंग 50 लोग ऑलमोस्ट 50 हो चुके हैं हाउ
आर यू टुडे सर आई एम गुड आई एम गुड सर
शुरू करने से पहले एक बार पीछे टॉपिक समरी
कर दीजिए तो बहुत हेल्प होगी शुरू करने से
पहले समरी करने का कोई फायदा नहीं है
क्योंकि पहले के जो वीडियोस है जो क्लासेस
है ऑलरेडी उनकी रिकॉर्डिंग अवेलेबल है तो
आप उनकी रिकॉर्डिंग देखिए राइट जस्ट सी द
रिकॉर्डिंग ट्स
इट दैट विल हेल्प यू मच ठीक है वो आपकी
बहुत हेल्प कर देंगी आपको रिकॉर्डिंग
देखना है ट्स
इट ओके
चलिए ओके ओके
ओके
जस्ट वेट गाइस जस्ट वेट मैं एक चीज कर रहा
हूं मैं वो चीज यहां पर कर लेता
हूं
हां आज हम लाइव वेबसाइट पे अच्छा आप में
से लाइव वेबसाइट
पे कौन-कौन चाहता है एक्सस के लिए हम हंट
करें बता दीजिए मुझे डू यू वांट अस टू हंट
ऑन लाइव वेबसाइट्स कि हम लाइव वेबसाइट्स
पे हंट करें आज लाइव हम सारी चीजें देखें
जो लाइव प्रोग्राम्स है बग बाउटी
प्रोग्राम्स चलाते हैं ओबवियसली वी विल बी
डूइंग ऑल द एथिकल वे बिकॉज हमारे पास
परमिश होंगी उन वेबसाइट्स भंड करने का
बिकॉज दे आर रनिंग बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम्स
राइट ओके तो चलिए तो लाइव के लिए तो काफी
लोग बहुत खुश हो जाते हैं काफी लोग लाइव
के लिए बहुत ही खुश हो जाते हैं लाइव ही
करना है उनको ठीक है चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते
हैं एंड काफी काफी काफी मजा आने वाला है
एंड मैं आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा जो भी
लोग इस सेशन को देख रहे हैं आप सबसे
रिक्वेस्ट है कि इसकी पार्ट वन ऑलरेडी जो
है हमने करा दी है एंड आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है
टू गो एंड वच द पार्ट वन फर्स्ट अगर आपने
नहीं देखी है तो फिर आप इसको कंटिन्यू भी
कर सकते हैं या तो आप इसको भी देख सकते
हैं फिर पार्ट वन देख सकते हैं जो कि डे
18 में कवर्ड है यहां पे ठीक है तो चलिए
अब मैं सबसे पहले एक चीज यहां पे बताना
चाहता हूं जैसे मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं
मैं एक लाइव वेबसाइट जो है उसको एज अ
टारगेट लेना चाहता हूं तो हम किसी भी एक
प्लेटफार्म से लाइव टारगेट चूज कर सकते
हैं ठीक है तो लाइव टारगेट चूज करने के
लिए हम सबसे पहले चलते हैं पोस का बग
क्राउड बग क्राउड पे चल जाते हैं या तो हम
ओपन बग बाउंट पे भी जा सकते हैं ओपन बग
बांटी . ठीक है आप इस पर भी जा सकते हैं
ugb.ac.in
जो यूजुअली आपको बक क्राउड हैकर वन पे
नहीं मिलते हैं आपको यहां पे वैसे
प्लेटफॉर्म्स वैसे डोमस और वैसे
प्रोग्राम्स मिल सकते हैं एंड कुछ कंट्री
स्पेसिफिक प्रोग्राम्स भी मिल जाएंगे जो
इजी टू हंट हो सकते हैं आपके लिए मे बी
आपको वहां पे बग्स मिल जाए आपके हौसले को
बुलंद करेगी वो आपके अंदर एक एक जज्बा
जगाए गी फॉर बग बाउटी फॉर एक्सेस हंटिंग
ठीक है तो चलिए आज हम ऑटोमेटेड मैनुअल
अप्रोच सब देखने वाले हैं देखो एक्सेसेस
फाइंड करते टाइम तुम एक चीज का हमेशा
ध्यान दो ठीक है हमेशा एक चीज का ध्यान
दो यहां पे चूज एन एक्सस पेलोड ठीक है ठीक
है मोस्टली जो एक्सस पेलोड आप चूज कर रहे
हो वो ट्राई करो कि इवेंट हैंडलर वाले
एक्सस पेलोड्स चूज करो जैसे आईएमजी एसआरसी
चूज कर सकते हो एसवीज अ एसवीजी चूज करके
ऑनलोड लगा सकते हो आईएमजी एसआरसी ऑनलोड ऑन
एरर ये सब चीजें लगा सकते हो व्हाट एवर तो
ऐसे जब आप तुम पेलो चूज करते हो ना तो कुछ
रिस्ट्रिक्शंस बाइ डिफॉल्ट बायपास हो जाती
है ये मैं आपको बताऊंगा ये सीएसपी की
कहानी है सीएसपी वगैरह जब यूज होता है
कंटेंट सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी जिसको बोलते हैं
उस टाइम पर अगर कुछ चीजें आप पहले से यूज
कर रहे हो कुछ प्री डिफाइंड पे लोट्स तो
ऑलरेडी बायपास हो जाती है एंड देन फदर
आपको बायपास अगर करना है तो आप अलग-अलग
सीएसपी डेरिवेटिव्स आप अपने लगा लगा के
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो अपने खुद के भी
डेरिवेटिव्स ठीक है फिलहाल के लिए कोई भी
एक एक्सेस पेलो चूज कर लो इंसर्ट दैट
पेलोड एवरी वेयर
पॉसिबल एवरी वेयर फ पॉसिबल का मतलब मैं
क्या बोल रहा हूं इस चीज को समझो जैसे कोई
भी इनपुट फील्ड है वहां डालो कोई भी किसी
भी तरह का इनपुट हो साइन अप कर रहे हो
लॉगइन कर रहे हो पासवर्ड चेंज ईमेल चेंज
प्रोफाइल अपडेट लॉगइन फॉर्म कांटेक्ट
फॉर्म लॉगइन या व्हाट एवर कुछ भी सर्च
फॉर्म आप वहां पे
डालो रीड द सोर्स को सोर्स पेज करो ट्राई
टू ट्राई टू एग्जीक्यूट
द पेलोड और और ट्राई टू
बायपास द
फिल्टर्स फिल्टर्स और जो भी मिटिगेशंस
लगाई गई है उनको बायपास करने की कोशिश करो
एज सिंपल एज दैट बस ट्स इट बस इतना ही
करना है ठीक है थैंक यू ग कम्युनिटी भाई
थैंक यू चलिए अब इतना करके और आपको
कंप्लीट और हां याद रखिएगा आप लोगों ने
बोला था सर गैप चाहिए गैप चाहिए कवर नहीं
कर पा रहे पिछले क्लासेस तो मैंने आपके
कहने पर गैप दिया लगभग तीन दिन का गैप दे
दिया तो मजा आया ना तीन दिन में प्रीवियस
लेक्चर कवर किए कि नहीं आपने पहले यह
बताइए तीन दिनों को एज अपॉर्चुनिटी लिया
कि एज अ हॉलिडे लिया आप में से कितने
लोगों ने तीन दिन जो गैप मिला आपको उसको
एज अपॉर्चुनिटी लिया और कितने लोगों ने
हॉलीडे की तरह एंजॉय कर लिया बस तीन दिन
में यह मुझे बता
दीजिए जस्ट लेट मी नो बताइए भैया कितने
लोग हैं आप लोग जिन्होंने ऐसा किया है
अपॉर्चुनिटी की तरह लिया या हॉलिडे की तरह
लिया एस अपॉर्चुनिटी और एस हॉलिडे
मैक्सिमम लोग
रिप्लाई
टा राकेश
कुमार चलो बढ़िया बढ़िया अपॉर्चुनिटी और
हॉलिडे एजाम दिया चलिए अच्छी बात
है लिटिल बिट लीड है जो लाइव अटेंड है
उनका तो थोड़ा टाइम और मिल गया थैंक यू
चलो बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया अपॉर्चुनिटी
चलिए बहुत बढ़िया अगर आपने अपॉर्चुनिटी की
तरह लिया बहुत अच्छे अब चलिए मैं यहां पे
मेरे पास अब मैं एक्सस की पेलोड की एक
लिस्ट बनाऊंगा अब देखो मैं क्या करूंगा ना
मैं बार-बार एक सिंगल सिंगल पेलोड तो
टेस्ट नहीं करूंगा सिंपल इतना टाइम है
नहीं मेरे पास तो मैं इसको ऑटोमेट करूंगा
ऑटोमेशन के लिए आपको चाहिए बर्ब शूट बर्ब
शूट का यूज आप कर सकते हो ऑटोमेट करने के
लिए अपने एक्सस अटैक को एंड बॉब शूट के
बारे में अगर नहीं पता भैया तो उसके ऊपर
भी हमने ऑलरेडी कवर कर दिया अरे हर चीज
कवर्ड है यार बस थोड़ा सा टाइम तो दो अपना
अपना टाइम हमें दो यहां पे आ जाइएगा लाइव
सेक्शन में नीचे आइएगा नीचे आइएगा नीचे
आइएगा एंड यहां पे थोड़ा सा नीचे आएंगे तो
आपको हमारी वीडियो मिलेगी डे फोर की बब
शूट इन डेप्थ ट्यूटोरियल आप इसको देख
लीजिएगा आपको क्लियर समझ में आ जाएगा बब
शूट को कैसे क्या यूज करना है और उसी का
एप्लीकेशन हम आज यूज करने वाले हैं एंड हम
देखने वाले हैं
चलिए तो हम एकदम सिप सिंपल सते हैं और याद
रखिएगा जो भी लाइव सेशंस होती है उनको
कंप्लीट देखना आपका फर्ज बनता है क्योंकि
लाइव सेशन में टॉपिक तो बहुत सिंपल मैं
डाल देता हूं जैसे डे 19 फाइंडिंग
एक्सेसेस ऑटोमेटेड एंड मैनुअल वे बट इसके
अंदर होता बहुत डिफरेंट वैरायटी होता है
बहुत डिफरेंट तरह का वैराइटीज होता है जो
आपको इसके अंदर मिलता है तो पूरा देखिएगा
तो आपको सारी वैराइटीज जो है ऑटोमेटिक
मिलेंगे और 55 लोगों ने बस लाइक किया है
और यहां पे 72 लोग देख रहे हैं भैया और
तुम लोग यार लाइक नहीं ठोको ग तो कैसे काम
चलेगा यार कैसे काम चलेगा बताओ तो चलिए
पहले आप ओपन बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम पे आ सकते
हैं यहां से सी ऑल बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स
पे जा सकते हैं और यहां से आप कुछ डिफरेंट
काइंड ऑफ बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स को चूज कर
सकते हैं अपने स्कोप के लिए ठीक है एक ये
हो गया एक हमारे बक क्राउड से तो भैया
हमारे ये सारे जो हैं वो तो है ही तो चलिए
और एक हम मैनुअली भी
googlegroups.com आपके नजर में जो भी
वेबसाइट है वेबसाइट पूरा बताइएगा वो आप
चैट बॉक्स में डाल सकते हैं वेबसाइट शायद
एज अ लिंक मे बी चैट बॉक्स में नहीं आएगी
तो आप ओवर मतलब उसका नाम बता दीजिएगा एंड
वी विल बी टेकिंग दैट
राइट धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद कॉलेज की है शांके अगर बक बाउटी
प्रोग्राम है तो रिपोर्ट कीजिए अदर वाइज
थोड़ा प्यार से उनको बताइए कि आपका
वल्नरेबल ऐसा है वैसा है उनको यह मत
दिखाइए कि आपने कोई डाटा डाउनलोड कर लिया
या पॉसिबली कर सकते हैं तो वो शायद भड़क
जाए फिर यह भी हो सकता है ठीक है तो
डिपेंड करता कॉलेज के
ऊपर यस प्रोफेशनल एडिशन हो ब ब शूट का तो
बढ़िया है बढ़िया है राइट चलिए तो चलिए
यहां पर हम कोई सा भी एक एक प्रोग्राम चूज
कर सकते हैं लेट्स चूज अ प्रोग्राम कोई सा
भी चूज प्रोग्राम कर सकते हैं या तो हम
मैनुअली भी चूज कर सकते हैं
लाइक इनटाइटल
वनरे वल्नरेबल
डिस क्लोज आवर प्रोग्राम वीडीपी ठीक है
एंड डटस वुड पिकर क्ल फार्म
इजी बहुत सारी है यहां पर रॉकेट
लेन ओके
अच्छा चलो यहां पर हमारे अमन भैया की
वेबसाइट को ओपन करते हैं अमन भैया पता है
ना कौन
है अमन भैया की वेबसाइट को ओपन करते हैं
चलिए लेट्स ओपन द अमन भैया
वेबसाइट चलिए अमन भैया का वेबसाइट है बोट
बोट की वेबसाइट है बोट बग बांटी बोट बग
बांटी है क्या हां जी बोट बग बाउटी है
चलिए बढ़िया है तो चलिए बोट बोट अमन भैया
की वेबसाइट ओपन करते हैं
ओके सो दिस वेबसाइट इज बोट lifestyle.com
यहां ओपन कर लेते हैं राइट लेट्स ओपन बोट
lifestyle.com यहां पे आ गया यहां पे देखो
अब यहां पे कहां-कहां हम अपना प्रोडक्ट या
फिर हमारा टगे हमारा जो स्क्रिप्ट है वो
डाल सकते हैं या हमारा पेलो डाल सकते हैं
जैसे यहां पे सर्च पैनल है तो यहां डाल
सकते हैं नीचे आ जाओ यहां पे फिलहाल हम
नॉर्मली डाल रहे हैं मैनुअली हम कर रहे
हैं नॉर्मली यहां पे एक ईमेल न्यूज़ लेटर
है तो न्यूज़लेटर को भी आप ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं कोई भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं है इसको आप
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं फरदर और भी जहां भी
कोई आप ट्राई कर सकते हैं कीजिए यहां पर
हम डालते हैं और यहां पर डालते डि फोनिक्स
य हमने डाला डि फोनिक्स लेट्स प्रेस एंटर
की जैसे हमने एंटर की
किया एंटर की क्लिक किया कंट्रोल यू किया
सोस स्पेस देखते हैं एंड कंट्रोल एफ करके
डिफन सर्च करते कहां पर है यह तो यहां पर
डि फोनिक्स हमें मिला सोर्स पेज में लेट्स
जूम इन ताकि आपको दिख जाए सॉरी कुछ ज्यादा
ही जूम इन कर
दिया चलिए तो लेट्स कंट्रोल एफ
डेनिक्स एंड यहां पे हमें डिफ्रॉक जो है
वो मिल रहा
है थोड़ा और जूम आउट कर देते
हैं
ओके कंट्रोल एफ डि
फोनिक्स ये रहा यहां प हमें डि फोनिक्स
मिला है एंड दिस इ सिंपली एक सर्च क्वेरी
में डि फोनिक्स हमारा रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है
ओबवियसली तो अब हम यहां पे सिंपल एक पेलो
डालेंगे
स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट की देन हम अलर्ट कर
देते हैं एंड अलर्ट के बाद हम ओबवियसली डि
फ्रक्स को ही चूज करते हैं सिंगल कोड के
अंदर में स्ट्रिंग हम दे रहे हैं यहां पे
तो सिंगल कोड के अंदर डाल देते हैं एंड
यहां स्क्रिप्ट टैब को क्लोज करते हैं एंड
प्रेस एंटर की लेट्स सी हमने यहां पे एंटर
की प्रेस किया एंड ट्स ऑल तो
यह यह अलर्ट आ गया है हमारे पास यह पता है
आपको यह अलर्ट आया हमारे पास बोट लाइफ
स्टाइल कॉ भैया यह देखिए आप पहले ये मतलब
नॉर्मल सा रिफ्लेक्शन था रोनिक्स का एंड
जैसे ही हमने डि फ्रक्स पे करके हमने
नॉर्मल स्क्रिप्ट लगाया नॉर्मल स्क्रिप्ट
लगाया यहां बोट लाइफ स्टाइल पे कुछ किया
नहीं है एंड वी गट डेनिक्स
अलर्ट समझ में आया वी गट द डेनिक्स अलर्ट
बोट lifestyle.com पे अब यहां
पे अब यहां पे थोड़ा सा चेंज करते हैं
यहां डे फ्रक्स वाली जो चीज है ना इसको
रिमूव करते हैं लेट्स रिमूव एंड यहां करते
हैं
डॉक्यूमेंट डॉट
कुकी एंड लेट्स प्रेस एंटर की डॉक्यूमेंट
डट कुकी एंड वी आर गो गेटिंग द कुकी
वैल्यू यह हमें कुकी वैल्यू मिल रही है
अलट में राइट वी आर गेटिंग द कुकी वैल्यू
ये अभी देखो अभी अभी देखो क्या
क्या ओ ओ भाई यह देखो क्या हो रहा है ये
वी गट द कुकी वैल्यू राइट तो यह भी हमें
मिल गया चलिए यह तो ये तो अलग ही अलग ही
गेम चल रहा है भाई अलग ही गेम चल रहा है
तो हमें कुकी वैल्यू मिल गई यहां पे अब एक
काम करते हैं डॉक्यूमेंट ड कुकी को यहां
पे हम बेसिकली यहां पर हम क्या करते हैं
लेट्स लेट्स पुट
ऑन समथिंग लाइक अलर्ट एंड देन
डॉक्यूमेंट डट डोमन एंड लेट्स डॉक्यूमेंट
डन बो lifestyle.com सो इट्स रिफ्लेक्टिंग
बोला लाफ स्टाल कॉ है ना या सो यह हो गया
अब हम एक काम करते हैं ना लॉग इन भी कर
लेते हैं एक बार लेट्स ट्राई टू लॉग इन एक
बार हम लॉग इन करते पहले अकाउंट में लॉगइन
करके एक बार चेक करते हैं लेट्स लॉग इन
यहां मैं यहां मैं नंबर डाल देता हूं सो
लेट मी
एंटर हमारी कंपनी का नंबर मैं डाल देता
हूं यहां पे लेट मी एंटर द नंबर लेट्स
सेंड द
ओटीपी लेटस
सी तो आई थिंक ओटीपी आया
1955 ये ओटीपी आया ये तो शुरू होते ही
खत्म हो गया यहां मैं नंबर डालता हूं यहां
नेम डालता हूं डि फ्रक्स साइबर
सिक्योरिटी ग्रेट ग्रेट बस बस स्पैम मत
करो ईमेल आईडी डाल देता हूं मैं तो ईमेल
आईडी डालता हूं टीम डि फ्रक्स @
gmail.com एंड डिफ ठीक है अब यहां पे मैं
सबमिट करता हूं अच्छा देखिए यहां पे भी
तुम अपना पेलो डाल सकते हो अगर कोई पलट
तुम्हें चेक करना है नेम वाले कैटेगरी में
तो तुम यहां भी डाल सकते हो कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है इसमें तुम क्या कर सकते हो ना इस
नेम कैटेगरी में डालने के लिए तुम इसको
इंटरसेप्ट करके भी यूज कर सकते हो
इंटरसेप्ट करो और फुल नेम के जगह पे यहां
पे अपना पेलोड एंटर कर दो ठीक है वो भी
ट्राई आउट तुम कर सकते हो ये भी एक अप्रोच
होता है ये भी एक तरीका होता है ठीक है ये
भी एक तरीका होता है जैसे फुल नेम को यहां
पे किया ना अब इसको तुम बब सूट से क्या
करो इंटरसेप्ट करो और फुल नेम की जगह
एक्सस की पे लट डालो एंड इसको या तो
इंट्रूडर को भेजो वहां पोजीशन सेट कर दो
और इसके जगह पर एक्सस पलट की लिस्ट डाल दो
सारे पलट को टेस्ट करेगा कि कौन सा पेलोड
इसम एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है पर्टिकुलर ठीक
है ओके चलिए तो डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
यहां पर हमने क्या किया हम यहां पर सबमिट
कर लेते हैं बाद में इसको देखते हैं सबमिट
करके हम इस ब क्रिएट कर लेते हैं तो ह या
सक्सेसफुली लगड इन अमन भैया आपकी वेबसाइट
ने तो पॉप अप मार दिया भाई मिस्टर अमन
गुप् कि वेबसाइट ने पॉप अप मार दिया अब
हमने क्या किया यहां पे हमने लॉग इन कर
लिया है वी हैव लॉग इन एंड अब हमने यहां
पे इसको फिर से रीलोड कर लिया पेज को एंड
ऑब् वियस यू कैन सी द माय अकाउंट
पेज तो यहां पे माय अकाउंट पेज आ चुका है
यू कैन क्लियर सी हियर यहां पे मैनेज
एड्रेस का है माय ऑर्डर्स का है तो माय
ऑर्डर्स वाला सेक्शन एक बार चेक करेंगे
एंड यूआरएल पे भी आप देखेंगे कहीं कोई
पैरामीटर तो रिफ्लेक्ट नहीं हो रही है एंड
माय ऑर्डर्स में कुछ ऐसा हमने कुछ यहां
देखा नहीं है मैनेज एड्रेस पे चलते हैं
ओबवियसली यहां पे इनपुट फील्ड जरूर होगा
मेरे ख्याल से ऐड एड्रेस का फील्ड है
बिल्कुल तो ऐड एड्रेस में हम यहां पे कर
सकते हैं वो काम जो हम कर रहे थे तो
बेसिकली वी आर गोइंग टू एंटर अ सिंपल सा
पेलोड ठीक है एक सिंपल सा पेलोड डालते हैं
ऐड ऐड वाले में इस वाले में ठीक है तो हम
यहां पे नॉर्मल सा स्क्रिप्ट अ अलर्ट एंड
यहां पे हम डाल देते हैं डि
फ्रक्स एंड यहां पे हम स्क्रिप्ट को क्लोज
कर देते हैं एंड इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं
ठीक है हम सिंपल सा पेलो डालते हैं यहां
पे स्क्रिप्ट अलर्ट कर दिया डिफर डाल दिया
एंड यहां पे भी हम सेम डाल देते हैं
लोकेशन में पिन कोड में हम डाल देते हैं
यहां पे
अ एक पिन कोड डाल दिया सिटी में हम डाल
देते हैं न्यू सिटी में भी हम डाल देते
हैं अपना पेलोड स्टेट में दिल्ली सिलेक्ट
कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पे एड्रेस टाइप में
कर देते हैं
होम यहां भी पेलो डाल देते हैं लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग यहां पे जब हम ऐड एड्रेस
प क्लिक करते हैं देखते हैं क्या होता है
लेट्स सी अ ओके डन कुछ हुआ नहीं अभी
फिलहाल चलते हैं अकाउंट पे
एंड गो टू द मैनेज
एड्रेस
एंड ओके हमारा एड्रेस सेव नहीं हुआ है
राइट हमने यहां पर एड्रेस डाला हुआ था ना
बट वी
डिडेंट इसने एड्रेस सेव नहीं किया है गाइस
ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात
है यहां पे एड्रेस यहां पे किया यहां पर
डाला यहां डाल देते हैं पिन कोड यहां पे
मैं डाल देता हूं एंड सिटी न्यू ल्ली डाल
देता हूं एक बार ठीक है सिटी में न्यू
दिल्ली डाल देता हूं स्टेट में मैं दिल्ली
डाल देता हूं यहां पे एंड यहां पे होम कर
देते हैं एंड लेट्स नाउ सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग एक बार यहां पे अब देखते हैं ऐड
एड्रेस करके कुछ होता है
क्या इज इट सेविंग द एड्रेस ये देखना
जरूरी है सेव नहीं कर रहा है कहीं ना कहीं
से फिल्टर आउट हो रहा है आपका एड्रेस
दैट्ची बात है दिस इज गुड थिंग सो
ओबवियसली नहीं हुआ है अब एक काम करता हूं
मैं एक रियल एड्रेस डाल देता हूं मतलब
रियल मतलब वैसे ही डाल देता हूं अ
सराय लोकेशन बेस सराय पिन कोड
110016 न्यू दिल्ली स्टेट में यहां पर
न्यू दिल्ली डाल देते हैं ए यहां होम डाल
देते हैं अब एड्रेस ऐड करते हैं य एक
सिंपल सा रियल एड्रेस है तो आई थिंक अब यह
हो जाना चाहिए फिर भी अगर नहीं हो रहा है
तो फिर तो कुछ ना कुछ गड़बड़ है बट ठीक है
अब तो मेरे ख्याल से हो हा जी हो गया तो
एक एड्रेस आपका शेव हो चुका है यहां पे यह
होम ये आ रहा है अब इसको एडिट करते हैं
एंड अब जो है ना हम एक पेलो को यहां पर
टेस्ट करते हैं इस वाले ओनली दिस फीड वी
आर गोइंग टू टेस्ट द पेलोड एंड सेव करते
हैं लेट्स सी हमारा यह आया इस तरीके से
कंट्रोल य करते हैं एंड यहां पर देखते
अलर्ट हमारा कुछ कहीं पर आया है कि नहीं
आया है इफ वी आर सीइंग एनी काइंड ऑफ अलर्ट
एनी वेयर तो हम देख लेते य
पर कंट्रोल एफ
अलर्ट आई डोंट थिंक
सो कि हमें कहीं पर अलर्ट मिला
है ओके हमने ने यहां पे डेनिक्स डाला हुआ
था सो लेट्स
सी ओके सो कहीं भी नहीं है हमारा डे
फ्रक्स जो है जो हमने पेलो डाला था वो
कहीं रिफ्लेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है
राइट नेम डि फोनिक्स ने ईमेल फर्स्ट नेम
दिस इज द डिफो डिफोकस साइबर सिक्योरिटी
डिफो डिफो एंड डिफो निक्स एंड डिफन या तो
कहीं पे ये रिफ्लेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है तो
कोई बात नहीं इट्स नॉट वर्किंग चलो एडिट
कर लेते हैं हर एक फील्ड हर एक वैल्यू
आपको करनी है याद रखिएगा हर एक फीड हर एक
वैल्यू बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है दिस
वेरी वेरी मच इंपॉर्टेंट वेरी मच
इंपोर्टेंट ठीक है तो यहां पर मैं अब इसको
छोड़ के मैं क्या करता हूं हाउस नंबर छोड़
के यहां पर हाउस नंबर में मैं एक बार चेक
कर लेता हूं एंड देन सेव करते हैं लेट्स
सी इट एग्जीक्यूटिंग और
नॉट आई थिंक इट्स नॉट नो सिटी में डाल के
देख लेते हैं सेव लेट्स सी नो न इसको चेक
कर लेते एक बार सेव करते हैं इज इट आई
थिंक नो नो कहीं पे भी ये नहीं कर रहा है
कोई बात नहीं कोई टेंशन नहीं है हम छोड़
देंगे कोई ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेना है ठीक
है वी आर नॉट गोइंग टू टेक मच टेंशन हियर
तो इसको तो पहले छोड़ देते हैं चलो यहां
पे आ गया अब हम यहां पे नॉर्मल से सर्च
में अगेन ओ हो हो हो हो हो हो हो हो दिस
इज रिफ्लेक्टिंग गाइस डॉक्यूमेंट और डोमेन
था क्या लेट्स सी
व्हाट ओके
सो व्ट हम कौन सा पेलोड यूज कर रहे हैं ये
डॉक्यूमेंट ड डि फोनिक्स वाला है ना ओके
डि फोनिक्स है ये ओनली डि फोनिक्स है ठीक
है तो यहां पे तो नहीं हो रहा ये चीज बट
यहां पे ओबवियसली इट विड इट वुड बी
रिफ्लेक्टिंग क्योंकि हमारा जो डाला हुआ
था डॉक्यूमेंट डॉ डोमेन डाला हुआ था
ओबवियसली एंड इफ यू आर रीलोडिंग इट लेट्स
पुट द यहां पे तो
यस एंड लेट्स एंटर दिस वन लेट्स एंटर एंड
बो साइड ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है तो
ओके यहां पर इसको तो अभी हटा देते हैं
इसको हटा देते हैं अब मेरे को एक चीज और
आपको दिखानी है इसके ऊपर ही चलो देखते हैं
लेट्स सी ऑन इट ऑन दिस डोमेन आल्सो अब
मुझे क्या है मेरे को तो एक सर्च फॉर्म
मिला अब मेरे को और भी चीजें देखनी है
इसके अलग-अलग वेब पेजेस को आप एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हो लाइक यहां पे है ब्लॉग्स का है
चलो रेफर एनन का है चलो करियर्स का है चलो
रिस्पांसिबल
सॉरी
क्या हुआ बोट लाइफ स्टाइल राइट ब्लॉक्स का
खोला रेफर ए अन का खोला
हमने देन हम स्टोर लोकेटर पर चल सकते हैं
करियर्स में तो आ रहा है सोशल
रिस्पांसिबली चल सकते हैं कैटेगरी में है
अलग-अलग यहां पर कैटेगरी चलिए बहुत बढ़िया
नीचे की तरफ आते हैं नीचे की तरफ आते हैं
लेट्स सी व्ट वी कैन
ओपन सिक्योरिटी ठीक
है एफ क्य खोल सकते हैं ट्रैक र ऑर्डर खोल
सकते हैं
ओके वारंटी एंड सपोर्ट को ओपन कर सकते
हैं ओके ट्स ऑल यहां पे भी हम ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं हालांकि यह न्यूज़लेटर है
यहां पे आप ट्रा ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो बट
वही है कि यह ईमेल आईडी का यहां पे मांगता
है कि ईमेल आईडी एक डालो तो यहां पे हम
फिलहाल के लिए छोड़ देते हैं यहां पे
फाइंड स्टोर का ऑप्शन आ रहा है फाइंड
स्टोर पे आएंगे यहां देखते हैं कुछ हो
सकता है क्या नथिंग हियर दैट वी कैन डू
यहां पे ये स्टोर्स के एड्रेस है दैट ऑट
यहां पे कोई भी हमारे पैरामीटर नहीं है
फिलहाल के लिए अभी नॉर्मली जो हमें नहीं व
चीज हम अभी देखेंगे अभी हम ट्राई करेंगे
फाइंड करने का अभी देखते
जाओ पूरी की पूरी वेबसाइट रेबल है चलो
देखते हैं य प नीचे आते हैं नीचे आते हैं
नीचे आते हैं नॉट फाइंडिंग एनीथिंग
इंटरेस्टिंग हियर लेट्स गो टू द
सिक्योरिटी य सिक्योरिटी डिस्क्लोजर इनका
है सॉरी तो यहां पर आप इसको मेल कर सकते
हैं सिक्योरिटी एट द इमेजिन मार्केट
इंडिया इनके बक को रिपोर्ट करने के लिए या
यहां से भी शायद कहीं से ना कहीं से तो
होगा बग रिपोर्ट करने
का ओके एफ क्यू है यहां पे एफ क्यू में
कुछ है क्या हमारे काम का कुछ है क्या
नहीं है बट ऑर्डर ट्रैकिंग ऑर्डर ट्रैकिंग
में यहां पर डाल सकते हैं बट ऑर्डर नंबर
यहां डाल सकते हैं ऑर्डर नंबर में अपना
स्क्रिप्ट डाल दीजिए मोबाइल नंबर में आप
मोबाइल नंबर डाल दीजिए क्योंकि मोबाइल
नंबर ऑलवेज क्या होते हैं फिल्टर्ड हो ही
जाते हैं जनरली तो मोटरसाइकिल्स जो है वो
हम सिलेक्ट कर लेते हैं यहां वेरीफाई करते
हैं ओके बस बस एंड दिस इज बस थ्री बसेस
वेरीफाई डन एंड लेट्स सी ट्रैक ट्रैक आईडी
फॉर्मेट इज इनवैलिड ओबवियस है ओबवियस है
ट्रैक आईडी फॉर्मेट इनवैलिड है यहां पे
बता रहा है चलो कोई बात नहीं हम इसको अभी
और भी अलग तरीके से देखेंगे यह है सपोर्ट
पेज एंड सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग बात इनका एक
सपोर्ट का सब डोमेन है स lifestyle.com
एंड यहां पे एक सर्च पेज है जो कि एक
डिफरेंट सर्च पेज है तो यह अच्छी बात है
चलिए यह मुझे अच्छी लगी यहां पे नीचे आते
हैं नीचे कुछ और भी है क्या अ डिस्कवर हाउ
क्लेम वारंटी ओके इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं और
कुछ है क्या यहां पे नथिंग ए क्लेम वारंटी
ओके यहां पे भी है ग्रुप यहां पे कर लेते
हैं प्रोडक्ट प्रोडक्ट नेम चलो प्रोडक्ट
नेम में हमने डाल दिया पिन कोड
0016 ठीक है इसमें हम सबमिट करते हैं
प्रोडक्ट नॉट सिलेक्टेड ओके प्रोडक्ट हमने
सिलेक्ट नहीं किया तो ओबवियसली ये
प्रोडक्ट सिलेक्शन का है तो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है इसको हटा देते हैं बोट ब्लॉग्स का
आया है बोट ब्लॉग्स में कुछ है क्या
इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ वी आर नॉट गेटिंग समथिंग
एनीथिंग इंटरेस्टिंग रेफर एंड नहां रेफर क
गया चलो रेफर में यहां पर डाला हमने
स्क्रिप्ट यहां
पे फोन नंबर डाल दिया एंड
सबमिट प्लीज मैच द रिक्वेस्टेड फॉर्मेट
इन्होंने एक प्री डिफाइंड फॉर्मेट डाल रखा
है उसको मैच करने के लिए बोल रहे हैं
ओबवियसली और कुछ नहीं है तो मैं यहां पे
डालता हूं
नितेश एंड
सिंग सबमिट नहीं हो रहा ये इट इज नॉट
एग्जीक्यूटिंग राइट सो कोई बात नहीं इसको
रिमूव करते हैं एंड यहां पे आ रहे है बट
सपोर्ट ऑडर ट्रैकिंग हट गया हमारा स कू हट
गया सिक्योरिटी दिस इज द ईवेस्ट मैनेजमेंट
एंड दिस इज सपोर्ट सो बोट सपोर्ट बोट
सपोर्ट का एक अलग पेज है सोब
lifestyle.com ठीक है हम इस पे चलते हैं
यहां पे हमें मिला है एक सर्च बार यहां हम
अपना डालेंगे स्क्रिप्ट ठीक है चलिए यहां
मैंने डिफर डाला एंटर किया एंड वी डिड नॉट
गेट द एनी वी डिड नॉट गेट एनी रिजल्ट्स
सोर्स कोड देखेंगे डि फोनिक्स देखेंगे
कहीं पे आ रहा है क्या अरे ये बुकमार्क
क्यों आ रहा है भाई कंट्रोल ए करते हैं डि
फ्रॉक्स
ओके सो यहां
डिफ्रॉक्ड
फोनिक्स हमें डि
फ्रक्स जो है
यह रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है बट आप देख सकते
हैं य डि फ्रक्स जो रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है ट
इज बी
ट्रंट ट्रंक कर दिया गया इनको तोड़ दिया
गया है प हमारा जो कोड है स्क्रिप्ट अल डि
फोनिक्स यह इसको ना ब्रेक डाउन कर दिया
गया है आर यू सी
गा कि किस तरीके से यह ब्रेक डाउन हुआ है
स्क्रिप्ट अलर्ट इस तरीके से करके तो अब
यहां पर हम क्या कर सकते हैं सो दैट हमारा
यहां पर पूरा का पूरा स्क्रिप्ट रन हो जाए
ऐसा कुछ कर दे अगर तो बताइए यहां पर
ट्रंकड फॉर्म में आपका शो हो रहा है
बेसिकली
एंड अब यहां पे यह जो फिल्टर आउट हो रहा
है आपका हमारा जो पेलोड है दिस पेलोड
नीड्स टू बी स्केप मतलब इस फिल्ट्रेशन को
स्केप करना है आपको एंड एक प्रॉपर हमारा
होना चाहिए क्या एक हमारा फिल्टर होना
चाहिए तो हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं जरूरी
नहीं है कि ये वल्नरेबल होगा ही बट या वी
कैन डेफिनेटली गो एंड ट्राई आउट ठीक है
पैरामीटर भी है यहां पे यूआरएल पे याद
रखिएगा दिस पैरामीटर इज q क्य तो पैरामीटर
वाली भी काम कर सकता हू ऑटोमेशन के लिए तो
अब मुझे बता बताइए आप में से कि हम यहां
क्या-क्या पॉसिबिलिटीज हमारी हो सकती है
एंड व्हाट एल्स वी कैन
डू क्या कर सकते हैं इनकोड कर सकते हैं
चलिए बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया चलिए तो हम
क्या करते हैं एक बार इनकोड डिकोड प चलते
हैं इनकोड
डिकोड यहां पे आपको एक यूआरएल मिलती है आप
अपने पेलोड्स को इनकोड करके भी ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं टू एग्जीक्यूट ठीक है सिंगल
इनकोड मल्टीपल इन डबल इनकोड ट्रिपल इनकोड
ऐसे करके आप एक बार दो बार तीन बार इनकोड
करके भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं हमारी जो पेट थी सिंपल यह
थी स्क्रिप्ट अलट इनिक्स एंड ट्स इट इसको
हम क्या कर देते
हैं इनकोड कर देते
हैं कुछ इस तरीके से डिनर करते करते आपका
वीडियो देख रहा बहुत बढ़िया डीजे यह इस
तरीके से हमने इनकोड कर दिया राइट अब हम
इस इनकोडेड पेलोड को कॉपी करते हैं यहां
पर एंड लेट्स पुट ऑन द सर्च
क्वेरी एज इनकोडेड पेलोड एंड प्रेस एंटर
लेट्स सी हमने एंटर प्रेस किया कुछ हुआ
क्या हमने एंटर प्रेस किया बट हमें कोई
अलर्ट नहीं आया लाइक हमें कोई अलर्ट नहीं
आया सो लेट्स डू वन थिंग लेट्स सी द सोर्स
कंट्रोल एफ एंड देखते हैं डेफॉक्स इस बार
कैसे आया हुआ है तो ओके ओके ओके ओके एक
चीज देखो हमारा जो इनकोडेड पलट था जैसा का
तैसा एग्जीक्यूट हो चुका है यहां पे फिर
भी
हमें अलर्ट तो नहीं आया यहां पर अब इसके
पीछे क्या हो सकता है बताइए आप लोग व्ट
एल्स कैन बी देयर यह क्या हो सकता है इसके
पीछे कहानी यह टाइटल टैग भी है यहां
पर यहां पर टाइटल टैग भी है जहां तक मुझे
दिख रहा है टाइटल यहां क्लोज हो रहा है
यहां पर आपने इनकोड कर दिया नाउ व्ट एल्स
कैन बी डन हियर आप में से बताइए अगर आपको
लग आपको कुछ आईडिया है तो क्या आप कर सकते
क्या आपको करना चाहिए चलिए जल्दी बताइए
मुझे कि कुछ हो सकता है कि नहीं हो सकता
है फटाफट फटाफट जल्दी जल्दी बताइए जल्दी
बताइए जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी लेट मी नो
गा जितना भी दिमाग है लगा
लो अरे भैया पहले पॉप आया था व दूसरा
डोमेन था यार यह है सपोर्ट बोट लाइफ
स्टाइल दूसरा सब डोमेन नहीं है चलो बताओ
जल्दी एपीआई पेन टेस्टिंग आएगा भाई आएगा
टेंशन मत
लो वेबसाइट का टाइटल चेंज कर दो अरे भाई
इसको तो बताओ टाइटल को क्लोज करके अच्छा
और
[संगीत]
लोग वेबसाइट हैक पेल डालते हैं वह वेबसाइट
पर आईपी ब्लॉक कर देती है इसका क्या
सोल्यूशन है चलो बताएंगे उस परे भी आएंगे
टेंशन मत लो स्टाइल टैग में जरा ठीक है
इवेंट हैंडलर यूज करते हैं सर यूज करते
हैं सर ठीक है टाइटल प पहले पले ही क्लोज
कर दो आई एम कंप्लीट बिगनर ट्स वई ठीक है
सर बायपास टाइटल क्लोज कर दो यूआरएल प
करके दिखाओ कमेंट आउट करके भेजिए सर
स्क्रिप्ट टैग ब्लॉक
है स्क्रिप्ट टैग ब्लॉक
[संगीत]
है टाइटल टैग सब लोग बोल रहे टाइटल टैग
क्लोज कर दो टाइटल क्लोज कर दो चलिए हम एक
काम करते हैं हमने यहां पर ये इनकोडेड
यहां पर डाला था ओबवियसली हम क्या करते
हैं यहां पे टाइटल को क्लोज करके देखते
हैं टी आई टी एल ई एंड लेट्स डन लेट्स डू
स डू दिस एंड प्रेस एंटर की अगेन हमारा
कुछ नहीं हुआ कंट्रोल यू करते हैं कंट्रोल
एफ करते हैं डिफ्रॉक सर्च करते हैं एंड
अगेन टाइटल को हमने जब किया तो इसने भी
यहां पे ट्रंकड यहां पे दिया हमें रिजल्ट
हमें दिया है इसको भी यहां पर टाइटल को
ट्रंक करके दिया गया है यहां पे ओबवियसली
तो हम टाइटल को भी इनकोड करके देख सकते
हैं राइट वी कैन ट्राई आउट फॉर द टाइटल
इनकोडिंग आल्सो हां पॉली क्लट भी चेक कर
सकते हैं ओबवियसली कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तो
हम टाइटल को भी एक बार इनकोड करते हैं
इसको डिकोड करो यहां पर एंड यहां पर जो हम
टाइटल को जो हम टाइटल को क्लोज कर रहे ना
टी आई टी एल ई यह रहा टाइटल ठीक है इसको
हम साथ में इनकोड करते हैं इनकोड इट एंड
लेट्स नाउ कॉपी दिस एंड लेट्स ट्राई इसको
ट्राई कर लेते हैं चलिए इसको हमने ट्राई
किया एंटर या एंड डिड वी गेट नहीं हमें
कुछ भी नहीं मिला यहां पे लेट्स कंट्रोल
यू कंट्रोल एफ डे
फोनिक्स एंड यहां प हमने टाइटल किया सो
हमें यहां पे इस तरह से कुछ मिला है
रिजल्ट अब बताइए
मुझे ठीक है मेन डोमेन पे करो भैया यहां प
हमने किया यहां पे एंड हमें वी डिन गेट
एनीथिंग यहां पे हमें टाइटल को हमने इनकोड
किया एंड हमें कुछ मिला नहीं एक काम करते
हैं हम इस पूरे को हम वापस से इनकोड करते
हैं डबल इनकोडिंग लगाते हैं वी आर गोइंग
फॉर द डबल इनकोडिंग लेट्स कॉपी इट एंड
लेट्स ट्राई इट
हियर ठीक है एंड लेट्स प्रेस एंटर लेट्स
सी वी आर डॉट वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग अब
एक काम करते हैं हमारा जो डिकोड इसको
डिकोड किया इसको डिकोड किया हम टाइटल जो
कर रहे हैं यहां पे टाइटल को हमने क्लोज
किया राइट वी आर क्लोजिंग द टाइटल थिंग
यहां पे हम इसके बाद यहां पे कमेंट भी लगा
देते हैं लाइक वी आर पुटिंग इट कमेंट
पुटिंग डाउन कमेंट यर तो बाकी जो चीजें
हैं उसको कमेंट आउट कर दे ये अब इसको हम
इनकोड करते हैं लेट्स इनकोड इट एंड लेट्स
कॉपी इट एंड लेट्स प्रेस लेट्स पेस्ट इट
हियर एज अ पेलोड एंड लेट्स सी वी आर नॉट
गेटिंग एनीथिंग लेट्स डबल इनकोड इट डबल
इनकोड करते हैं अब हम एज अ पेलो डालते हैं
यहां पे यहां पे प्रेस किया एंटर किया
अगेन हमने नहीं मिला हम ट्रिपल इनकोडिंग
करेंगे हम अगेन एक बार इसको उठाते हैं
लेट्स प्रेस एंड प्रेस एंटर की वी डिन गेट
एनीथिंग एक बार और इनकोड करेंगे
फाइव टाइम्स तक आप इनकोडिंग करके ट्राई
आउट मार सकते हो कोई भी दिक्कत नहीं है
फिलहाल के लिए बट हमें कुछ रिजल्ट्स यहां
पे कुछ खास नहीं मिल रहे हैं ओबवियसली वी
आर जस्ट मल्टीपल इनकोडिंग हम यूज कर रहे
और कुछ भी नहीं कर रहे हम एक काम करते हैं
लेट्स गो टू द बेस
64 इनकोडिंग डिकोडिंग जो भी है यहां चल
देते हैं बेस 64 प चल देते हैं इनकोड यहां
पर हमारा जो पेलोड है वो पेलोड एंटर कर
देते हैं राइट तो हमने यहां पर डिकोड कर
देना है जो हमारा पेलोड है और ओबवियसली ये
पेलोड है तो इसी को हम कॉपी कर लेते हैं
बेस 64 से हम यहां पे यहां डाल देते हैं
एंड यहां से हम इनकोड कर देते हैं सो वी
गट दिस वन लेट्स ट्राई टू पुट इट एज आवर
पलट चलिए पेलो डाला यहां एंटर किया वी आर
गेटिंग एनीथिंग नॉट वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
एनीथिंग
लेट्स इसको डाला एंड अगेन लेट्स इनकोड इट
ओबवियसली हमने थोड़ा सा डबल इनकोड कर दिया
एंटर किया वीड नॉट गेट एनीथिंग कुछ हमें
नहीं मिला
राइट आगे से जो टाइटल क्लोज हो रही है
उसको कमेंट करना पड़ेगा चलिए उसको भी एक
बार देख लेते हैं अगर ऐसा है
तो इफ यू आर सीइंग डूइंग लाइक दिस अगर आप
इसको कमेंट करने की बोल रहे हो टाइटल
क्लोज को इस तरीके से तो हम इस तरीके से
भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं दोनों ही कमेंट
कर देते हैं एंड देन हम एंटर प्रेस करते
हैं वी डट गेट एनीथिंग देन हम इसको इनकोड
करके डबल इनकोडिंग कर देते हैं कोई भी बात
नहीं है यहां पे अगेन इसको हम ट्राई आउट
करते हैं एंड अगेन नहीं मिल देखो जब ऐसा
कुछ हो जैसे कोई पैरामीटर है वहां पे तुम
ट्राई आउट कर रहे हो नहीं मिल पा रहा है
या नहीं हो पा रहा है कुछ भी व्हाट एवर
इसका मतलब ये नहीं है कि तुम उसमें अब
घुसे रह जाओ और तुम्हें एकदम से करना है
कि नहीं होगा ही होगा ऐसा नहीं है मो
मोस्ट ऑफ द ट्राई आप जब करोगे ऑब् वियस
ऑब् वियस यू विल गेट सक्सेस बट कई बार
आपको फेलियर भी मिलेगा कोई टेंशन नहीं है
अब हम इसमें एक चीज हम कर सकते हैं क्या
वो देखो मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पे हमें
यहां
पे हम यहां पे यह वाली यूआरएल की बात कर
रहे
हैं वी आर टॉकिंग अबाउट दिस यूआरएल अब हम
यहां पे एक ऑटोमेटेड वे यूज करने वाले हैं
जिसमें हम मल्टीपल पे लोट्स को चेक करने
वाले हैं अगेंस्ट द एक्सेसेस वनबिल हम
ट्राई करेंगे कि ये एक्चुअली वल्नरेबल है
या नहीं है ठीक है हम ट्राई आउट करने उसके
लिए हमें एक्सस की एक पेलोड की पूरी लिस्ट
चाहिए एंड वो लिस्ट कहां से मिलेगी तो वो
लिस्ट आप सेक लिस्ट से ले सकते हो सेक
लिस्ट पे जाओगे यहां
पे ठीक है एंड यहां जाओगे तो फजिंग में
चले जाना देन यू विल गो टू द फजिंग देन आप
एक्सेसेस पे आ जाना यहां
पे देन यू विल गेट अ लॉट ऑफ एक्सस पेलोड्स
यहां पे एक्सस वेक्टर सोमदेव अ यहां पे
चीट शीट पोर्ट्स फिगर वाली जो एक्सएसएस की
अ हमारी लिस्ट है वह सारी लिस्ट यहां पे
आपको मिल जाएगी बहुत ज्यादा बड़ी लिस्ट
होग 6000 के आसपास यह पेलोड्स हैं तो आप
इनको ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो इन पेलोड्स को
आप यूज़ कर सकते हो ब्रूट लॉजिक के
एक्सेसेस के पेलोड्स हैं 113 है यहां पे
आप इसके लिए भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो अ
बायपास स्ट्रिंग्स है कुछ यहां पे पेलोड
के तो आप इनको भी यूज कर सकते हो बायपास
वाले तो व्हाट यू कैन डू हम क्या कर सकते
हैं एक पेलोड का फाइल बना सकते हैं ठीक है
सो वी आर गोइंग टू मेक अ पेलोड फाइल
ओबवियसली तो हम यहां पे कर लेते हैं यहां
पे एक टेक्स्ट डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन कर लेते हैं
एंड यहां पे कर देते हैं एक्सस एंडटी
एक्सटी
दैट्ची ने भी पेलो है एक्सस वाले उसको पुट
डाउन करने वाले हैं ठीक है जो जो हम एक्स
के पेट बनाने वाले सिंपल हम उसको पुट डाउन
करेंगे तो हम क्या करते हैं यहां पर सेक
लिस्ट को ही ओपन कर लेते हैं पहले तो
ब्रूट लॉजिक वाली पेलो जो है हमारी एक्सस
की जो कि 113 लाइन की है सिंपल सा तो इसको
हम यहां
पर कॉपी कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पर पुट डाउन
कर लेते हैं देन वी आर मूविंग टू सम अदर
पेलोड
लाइक बायपास स्ट्रिंग्स को भी हम कॉपी कर
सकते
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं शायद मे भी कई बार
काम कर जाती है आपकी बायपास टेक्निक्स जो
होती है तो आप इसको भी डाल सकते हैं यहां
पे देन वी कैन मूव ऑन टू द नेक्स्ट पेलोड
लिस्ट एक्स की चीट शीट है यहां पे पोर्ट
स्गर वाली भैया हमारी जो उस दिन हमने देखा
था यह काफी बड़ी पट शीट है तो ओबवियसली यह
काफी बड़ी एक पेलोड लिस्ट आपकी जनरेट कर
देता है यहां पे एंटर कर दीजिए यहां पे तो
यह भी आपकी एक सीट तैयार हो चुकी है देन
हम यहां पे वेक्टर कुछ यहां पे है जिसमें
332 लाइन है ये ये वेक्टर्स है ये
एक्सेसेस वाले तो ओबवियसली वी कैन गो फॉर
इट बट अभी फिलहाल के लिए हम नहीं जा रहे
इसमें ओके यह देख लेते हैं या यू कैन
ट्राई आउट दिस वन सो जस्ट क्लिक ऑन रॉ एंड
जस्ट कॉपी एंड पेस्ट इट राइट राइट राइट सो
वी कैन पेस्ट इट हियर नाउ लेट्स गो एंड
लेट्स ट्राई कंटेंट यहां पे 4 साल पहले की
ठीक है एक्सेस विदाउट पेंट थेसिस सेमी
कॉलस ये विदाउट पैरेंस और सेमी कॉलस वाले
कुछ बायपास टेक बायपास आपके पेलोड्स हैं
तो इसको भी हम यूज कर सकते हैं सो
ओबवियसली वी हैव यूज्ड इट नाउ तो हमने
क्या किया ब्रू लॉजिक ये वाला कर लिया चीट
शट कर लिया बायपास स्ट्रिंग कर ली यहां पे
ये वाला एक बार देख लेते हैं अ दिस वन इज
299 बहुत ज्यादा बड़ी पेलोड लिस्ट है ये
बहुत ह्यूज है इसको रहने देते हैं हमारा
बस इतना हो गया काम खत्म हमने इसको सेव कर
लिया एंड
दैट्ची एक पूरी की पेलोड की एक लिस्ट पूरी
पेलोड की लिस्ट तैयार हो गई यहां पे
कंप्लीट पेलोड की लिस्ट यहां पर तैयार हो
गई एंड यह कितनी बड़ी पे पेलोड लिस्ट है
यह अभी हमें पता चल जाएगा आई थिंक बहुत
बड़ी हो गई है आई थिंक 8000 के आसपास हो
जाएगी शायद या 7000 के आसपास मेरे ख्याल
से यस 6207 बहुत बढ़िया है ये अब हमें
चाहिए बब शूट बब शूट हमें चाहिए बब शूट हम
ओपन कर लेते हैं लेट्स ओपन द बब शूट आई
होप कि आप सब के पास बब शूट है नहीं है
तो यह बफ शूट 1.7 वर्जन है जिसमें कि
स्पाइडरिंग फंक्शन जो है वो इनेबल्ड है अ
इजी टू स्पाइडर करने के
लिए
ओके सो लेट मी ओपन द बब शूट नेक्स्ट
स्टार्ट स्टार्ट
दैट्ची है यह रहा एंड इफ अगर आपके पास बॉब
शूट नहीं है तो हमने हमारी फ्री कोर्स जो
है हमारा हमारे ऐप पे हमारे डेनिक्स
अकेडमी पप पे तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
आपको प् स्टो पे चले जाना है यहां पे
सिंपली आपको सर्च करना है डेनिक्स डेनिक्स
सर्च करेंगे आपको हमारा ऐप मिल जाएगा इसको
इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा इसको ओपन कर लीजिएगा
ओपन जब करेंगे तो अपने फोन नंबर से लॉग इन
कर लीजिएगा
whatsapp2 शीट एंड ल जो रिसोर्सेस है वो
मिलेंगे ठीक है और थोड़ा बैक जाकर यहां पर
एक फाइल में जाएंगे तो यहां बब शूट प्रो
आपको 1.7 एक मिल जाएगा यू कैन जस्ट गो एंड
इंस्टॉल इट ठीक है बाकी प्रोसेस क्या है
वो आप देख सकते हैं आराम से आपको मिल
जाएगा हीं प भी ओके चलिए तो वी हैव
स्टार्टेड ओपन द बब शूट यहां प प्रॉक्सी
इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर लेता हूं अब मैं क्या
करूंगा लेट्स गो टू दिस यूआरएल ठीक है अब
मैं इस यूआरएल को लोड करूंगा एंड बॉब शूट
के अंदर में पहले मैं इसकी नेटवर्क
कॉन्फिन कर देता हूं
बफ सूट से इंटरसेप्ट करने के लिए मैनुअल
प्रॉक्सी सेटिंग करनी पड़ती है आप सबको
पता होगा यहां पर हमने यहां पर डाल
दिया एंड यहां हमने ओके कर
दिया
ओके लव फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान लव फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रदर वेलकम टू इंडियन
मोहम्मद नवाज शरीफ एंड इमरान खान दोनों ही
जीत गए हैं तो मुझे यह समझ में नहीं आया
कि दोनों कैसे जीत रहे हैं और कौन बनने
वाला है तो मुझे इसका थोड़ा बताइए आईम
गेटिंग
कंफ्यूज पाकिस्तान वाले भाई से पूछ रहा
हूं
मैं कर सकते हो ओस जप यूज कर सकते हैं नस
ऑनलाइन त्रिलोक धाकड़ थैंक यू फॉर द सुपर
चैट ब्रदर थैंक यू फॉर द सपोर्ट त्रिलोक
डीजे को जवाइन कर रहे हैं त्रिलोक धाकड़
डीजे एंड आरसी टेक इन दोनों को जवाइन कर
रहे हैं त्रिलोक
धाकड़
लेट्स सेलिब्रेट देयर फर्स्ट सुपर ऑन लाइव
स्ट्रीम सेलिब्रेट कर रहे हैं ओके
सेलिब्रेट सेलिब्रेट ठीक
है चलिए यहां पे आ चुके हैं अब हम यहां पे
हमने क्योंकि सेट कर दिया है हमने यहां पे
सेट कर दिया है नाउ वी विल गो टू द टारगेट
हम यहां पे इसको रीलोड करेंगे इस पेस को
वी आर गोइंग टू रीलोड इट सो दैट हमारे
टारगेट में ये चीज आ जाए तो अब हमारे
टारगेट में सपोर्ट बोट्स लाइफ स्टाइल यह
रहा ये यह रहा यह हमारा यूआरएल जो है यह
टारगेट जो है ये आ चुका है यहां पे हमारा
इसको मैं थोड़ा सा
इधर मैं कर देता हूं इसकी जरूरत क्योंकि
है नहीं उस उधर की साइड की चीज की
[संगीत]
एंड य मैं थोड़ा नीचे की तरफ एक्सपेंड कर
देता
हूं ठीक है एक्सपेंडिंग
र नाउ अब यहां पर हमारा जो टारगेट है
बेसिकली वह टारगेट है सपोर्ट बोटला स्ल कॉ
ठीक है इसमें भी हमारा एक पैरामीटर टारगेट
है पैरामीटर सर्च वाली तो हम एक काम करते
हैं व्ट वी आर गोइंग टू डू हम चलते हैं
यहां पर प्रॉक्सी प इंटरसेप्ट को हम यहां
पर ऑन कर देते हैं एंड यहां पर हम कुछ
सर्च करते हैं डि फोनिक्स लेट्स प्रेस
एंटर की एंड यह यहां पर हमें रिफ्लेक्ट
होना चाहिए हमें कैप्चर होना चाहिए
फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं
या सो हेयर इट इ स्कीमा सपोर्ट टारगेट
क्या है यह होस्ट यहां पर
फॉरवर्ड
इट नॉट गेट यरल गेट ए इक्वल टू वट दिस दिस
समथिंग डिफरेंट ओके ओके गट इट गट इट गट इट
इट गट इट चलो एक बार इसको हम स्कैन कर
देते हैं एक बार इसको क्या करते स्कैन मार
देते हैं यहां टारगेट हमें मिल चुका है य
पर अब हम क्या कर देते हैं यहां पर इसको
कर देते हैं ऐड टू स्कोप हम इसको स्कोप
में ऐड
करेंगे ठीक है स्कोप में करते
हैं यहां पर हमने य पर स्कोप में ऐड किया
फिल्टर पे लगाते हैं यहां पे करते हैं शो
इन स्कोप आइटम्स ओनली शो इन स्कोप आइटम्स
ओनली तो हमारे जो स्कोप में है सिर्फ उसी
को शो करेगा जो कि बट लाइफस्टाइल है अब हम
यहां पे क्या करते हैं देखो स्पाइडरिंग और
क्रॉल में क्या डिफरेंस है कुछ खास
डिफरेंस नहीं है यार क्रॉल मतलब ही वेब
पेजेस को स्पाइडर मतलब भी वही वेब पेज को
क्रोलिम ही होती है वो ठीक है तो इतना
टेंशन नहीं लेना है ठीक है
ओके चलिए अब यहां पे हम राइट क्लिक करते
हैं एंड स्पाइडर दिस होस्ट प क्लिक कर
देते हैं स्पाइडर दिस होस्ट प क्लिक
करेंगे तो स्पाइडर टाम में आप जाएंगे तो
स्पाइडरिंग यहां पे आप देख रहे हैं
स्टार्ट हो चुकी है एंड यहां टारगेट पे आप
आएंगे तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे टारगेट
की लिस्ट पॉपुलेशन होना शुरू हो चुकी है
एंड यहां पे हमें वैसे टारगेट हमें यूआरएल
चाहिए जिसमें पैरामीटर आता हो जो पैरामीटर
के साथ हो वैसे हमें यूआरएल चाहिए ठीक है
सो लेट्स वेट इसके लिए हम क्या कर सकते
हैं ये पैरामीटर वाले पे डबल क्लिक करोगे
तो पैरामीटर वाले जितने भी यूआरएल हैं 200
स्टेटस के साथ यानी रीचे बल है ओबवियसली
वो आपको यहां पे लिस्ट आउट करके मिल
जाएंगे यहां पे यह
देखो यह सारे पैरामीटर वाले हैं चलिए बहुत
बढ़िया बहुत सारे पैरामीटर भाई मजा आएगा
सो लेट इट स्पाइडर आई थिंक स्पाइडरिंग अभी
भी चल रही है
यस स्पाइडरिंग ल स्टिल
रनिंग सो लेट इट रन लेट स्पाइडर
कंपलीटली य तो हमें भी नहीं पता कौन बनेगा
पीएम
त्रिलोक धाकड़ प्लीज कैन यू चेक माय टूल
फॉर एक्सेस त्रिलोक बताइए आपको कौन सा टूल
है त्रिलोक त्रिलोक जी प्लीज बताइए आपका
कोई टूल है बताइए
मुझे चलिए सो हमने स्कैन कर दिया यहां
पर टारगेट प आ जाते य पर वी गट अ लॉट ऑफ
रिजल्ट्स यर एंड यहां पर हमें पैरामीटर्स
वाले रिजल्ट मिल चुके
हैं सॉरी य पहले यहां प गेट गेट पैरामीटर
यहां पे इस पर क्लिक करते यहां पर एंड
यहां पर आपको एक पैरामीटर मिलर है सर्च
क्य यहां पर सेम पैरामीटर है ये आई थिंक
यही वाला है यह पैरामीटर आपको मिल चुका है
तो हम इसको क्या करेंगे राइट क्लिक करेंगे
एंड सेंड
टू सेंड
टू इंट्रूडर चलिए हम ऑटोमेशन वाला करते
हैं
सेंडर कौन सा टूल है त्रिलोक आईम नॉट
गेटिंग योर टूल वो क्योंकि लिंक्स आप नहीं
सेंड कर पाएंगे लिंक्स नहीं आती है तो अगर
आपका टूल है तो आप उसका नाम और उस कहां पर
अवेलेबल है वो बता दीजिए तभी जाकर हम उसको
एक्सेस कर पाएंगे प्लीज प्लीज ठीक
है सो हमने इसको इंट्रूडर को सेंड किया है
पोजीशंस प आपको आना है इंट्रूडर प यहां पे
यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं बहुत सारे
पोजीशंस बने हुए हैं सबको क्लियर कर दीजिए
एंड हमें यहां पर पैरामीटर जो हमारा होने
वाला है वह क्य वाला क्यू पैरामीटर होने
वाला है एंड यहां पर हम जो यह जो आ रही है
ना सच टर्म हियर सर्च टर्म
यर
ठीक है q इक्वल टू सर्च टर्म यर यहां पर
हम कुछ एक्स वाई जड लिख देते हैं कुछ भी
टर्म लिख देते हैं एंड यहां पर हम यहां पर
इसको पोजीशन ऐड कर देते हैं यहां पे अब इस
पर्टिकुलर पोजीशन के लिए हम पेलोड की
लिस्ट डाल सकते हैं एंड हमारा पेलोड जो
लिस्ट कंटेन करता है जैसे हमारे पेलोड के
अंदर में यह सारी एक्सस की पेलोड्स है यह
सारी पेलोड्स को एक एक करके इस पर्टिकुलर
पैरामीटर पर लाके और चेक करेगा हमारा यह
इंट्रूडर फंक्शन अगर यह वा बल होगा तो
हमें पता चल जाएगा ठीक है कैसे होगा ये भी
देखिए ये भी देखिए राइट ये तुम शके शैंकी
तुम ही हो क्या यार तुम्हारा एक और
प्रोफाइल से आते हो शंकी करके वही हो
क्या या अब हमने ये कर लिया अब हम पे
लोट्स पे आते हैं हमारा अटैक टाइप स्निपर
चूज है अगर आप मल्टीपल पोजीशंस बनाना
चाहते हैं मल्टीपल पलट को यूज करना चाहते
हैं तो आप क्लस्टर बॉम भी यूज कर सकते हैं
ठीक है आप अभी स्निपर यूज कर रहे हैं एक
सिंगल पोजीशन बनाने के लिए यहां पर हम
करते हैं पेलोड्स प आते हैं यहां पर हम
सिंपल लिस्ट ही रखेंगे एंड यहां पर हम लोड
पर क्लिक करेंगे और हमारा जो एक्सेस का
पेलोड है उसको यहां पर चूज कर लेंगे कौन
सा हमारा एक्सस
का डेस्कटॉप प था ना
ये डेस्कटॉप डेस्कटॉप डेस्कटॉप पे यह रहा
एंड एक्सटी एक्टी ठीक है तो यह वाला था
हमारा ओपन कर लेते हैं एंड लेट्स सी पलट
काउंट आपको दिख रहा होगा 6207
627 पेलोड काउंट है यहां पे इतने पेलोड्स
है अब आप स्टार्ट अटैक पर क्लिक करेंगे
स्टार्ट अटैक प क्लिक करेंगे इंट्रूडर
आपका अटैक शुरू कर देगा एंड आप कुछ इस
तरीके से देख सकते हैं स्टार्ट अटैक जो है
स्टार्ट हो चुका है नीचे आप देख सकते हैं
6207 पेट्स में से यह 90 100 150 ये पेट्स
हर एक पलट को ट्राई कर रहा है उस
पर्टिकुलर पोजीशन के लिए एंड यहां पे आपको
कुछ रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे है स्टेटस में 200 आ
रहा है दैट इज कंपलीटली फाइन कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है मल्टीपल 200 से आ रहे हैं ठीक है
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव भी कुछ हो सकते हैं बट
हमारा काम है चेक करना कि कौन सा वर्क कर
रहा है तो मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ है
आपको अगर याद होगा कि इसमें से कौन सा
वर्किंग है कैसे चेक करते हैं इंट्रूडर
अटैक जब लच होता है तो कौन सा वर्किंग है
यह चेक कैसे करते हैं मुझे बताइए चैट में
क्या-क्या
हम जो लाइक क्या पोजी हम कौन सा फील्ड
देखते हैं क्या चीज के लिए देखते हैं बता
दीजिए
प्लीज अ ट्रिल ढाकर आपने ये फर्क किया है
या आप आपका ओरिजिनल टूल है कहीं से फर्क
किया है क्या आपने ये क्योंकि एक्सस
स्क्रॉलर नाम से एक और टूल था
शायद
चलिए लेंथ
ओके बिल्कुल सही लेंथ का एक बार चेक
करेंगे लेंथ चेक करेंगे स्टेटस चेक करेंगे
स्टेटस 200 है लेंथ इज मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट
लेंथ को हम चेक करेंगे राइट बहुत अच्छी
बात है आपको याद है तो
बहुत बढ़िया ग्रेट ग्रेट
ग्रेट या तो अभी हमारा 1000 पेलो टेस्ट
हुआ है बाकी और भी हो रहे हैं पेलो टेस्ट
तो हम होने देंगे बट हम यहां पे लेंथ के
लिए देखेंगे जीरो नंबर पे जो हमारा लेंथ
है वो है
16703 इससे बड़ा जो आ रहा है हम उसको
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं जैसे ये है 2 लाख
के आसपास आ रहा है 3 लाख के आसपास आ रहा
है तो हम इन पेलोड्स को भी ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है जैसे ये
हमारा पेलोड है राइट तो आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे ये पेलोड यूज हो रहा है यहां पे
एंड ये इनकोडेड फॉर्म में भी यूज हो रहा
है दैट इज द परफेक्ट थिंग सो व्हाट वी कैन
डू हम यहां पे इस पे लोट को ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं यहां से हमने कॉपी
किया हम इसको मैनुअली वैसे ट्राई कर सकते
हैं यहां पे जाके एंड सर्च पेज में डाल के
और यहां एंटर करके डाल सकते हैं कुछ अगर
मिलता है तो नहीं या तो हम इसको राइट
क्लिक करके शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर करेंगे
कॉपी करेंगे एंड यहां पे हम जाके एक नए
टैब में यहां पे ओपन करके देख लेंगे अगर
ये लाइक
कहीं से कुछ आता है यहां पे आपको
अ पॉप अप तो आपको यहां पे मिल जाता है
दैट्ची अलर्ट का आ रहा है यहां पे तो राइट
क्लिक करते हैं यहां से शो रिक्वेस्ट शो
रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर करते हैं कॉपी करते
हैं एंड लेट्स पुट इट हियर यहां पे एंड
एंटर करते हैं कुछ मिलता है तो ठीक है अगर
मान लो नहीं मिलता है मान लो कुछ भी तो हम
यहां पे इस पेलोड को कॉपी कर लिया यहां पे
और अब हम इसको इनकोड डिकोड भी कर कर सकते
हैं इनकोड डिकोड करके मैनुअली भी इनकोड कर
सकते हैं अगर कोई इनकोडिंग करनी है आपको
तो इनकोडिंग अब इसपे इनकोडिंग अप्लाई कर
दो यहां इनकोड कर दो डबल इनकोड कर दो चलो
एंड यहां पर कॉपी कर लिया एंड इसकी जगह पर
हम यहां पर एक बार फिर से इनकोडेड पेलो
डाल के और एंटर करके देख लेंगे अगर कुछ
मिलता है राइट अगर कोई वल्नरेबल है तो
हमें यहां पे मिल जाएगा राइट वीविल गेट
दैट तो ये हमें कुछ नहीं मिला यहां पे कुछ
और भी पेट्स यहां प देख सकते हैं ऑडियो
ऑटो प्ले कंट्रोल्स यहां पे आ रहा है ठीक
है मेन्यू आईडी ठीक है कंटेस्ट मेन्यू ओके
लेट्स चेक दिस वन
कॉपी दिस वन वी डट गेट एनीथिंग यहां पे भी
मतलब ये ऑटोमेटेड वे हो गया फॉर्म का है
यहां पे ऑन माउस ओवर का भी कुछ है क्या या
ऑन माउस ओवर ये वाला एक पेड हमें दिख रहा
है ऑन माउस ओवर का और तो कुछ है नहीं यहां
पे तो ऑन माउस एंटर है ऑन माउस ओवर नहीं
है ना ऑन माउस लीव है ऑन माउस डाउन है ऑन
माउस ओवर ये ऑन माउस ओवर का 3 लाख का मिला
हमें तो इसको मैं कॉपी कर लेता हूं शो
रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर एंड लेट्स कॉपी इट
लेट्स ट्राई टू डू दिस हियर
ओके यहां पे हमें कुछ भी नहीं मिला है चलो
यह तो चलो ठीक है यह तो हमें यहां पे कुछ
मिल नहीं रहा अभी फिलहाल के लिए इसको मैं
यहां पे साइड में करता हूं एक बार एंड
लेट्स ओपन इट हियर ओके एंड एक काम करते
हैं यहां पे टारगेट पे चलते हैं यहां पे
एंड इसको ज़ूम इन कर लेते हैं यहां पे एंड
यह जो हमारा था हम इसके रिस्पांस में एक
बार देख लेते हैं रिस्पांस में आप आओगे ना
देखो यहां
पे एक देखो यहां पे
रिस्पांस में तुम आए तो अब एक चीज ध्यान
दो जस्ट एक चीज मैं तुम्हें दिखाना चाहता
हूं बताना चाहता हूं कि क्या हो क्या रहा
है यहां पर रिस्पांस में जब तुम आओगे ना
इसके रिस्पांस को देखोगे ठीक है या तुम
यहां पर इसको क्या करो इंट्रूडर रिपीटर को
भेज दो रिपीटर में आते हैं यहां पर हम
इसको गो प क्लिक कर देते हैं यहां
रिस्पांस में आ जाते हैं ठीक है रिस्पांस
में आओगे तो इसके हेडस में आते हैं
रिस्पांस एडस
में यहां प सॉरी यहां प आ ग यहां पे तुम
यहां प आओगे ना तो यहां पर तुम्हें एक
दिखेगा कंटेंट सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी फ्रेम
एंसेट
सेल्फ ये तुम्हें एक चीज दिखेगी कंटेंट
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी ये सीएसपी इसको सीएसपी
शॉर्ट फॉर्म में बोलते हैं एंड सीएसपी का
मतलब क्या होता है मैं पहले आपको समझा
देता हूं एंड ये चीज बहुत लाइक इंपॉर्टेंट
होता है उसके बाद एक एक्स फ्रेम ऑप्शंस भी
आपका सेम ओरिजिन करके मैं आपको बताता हूं
रिस्पांस हेडर्स में ये कंटेंट सिक्योरिटी
पॉलिसी का क्या इंपॉर्टेंस है ठीक है पहले
आप इसको समझिए लेट्स
से हम बात करें सीएसपी
की
कंटेंट
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी सीएसपी राइट इसका यूज
क्यों होता है नाम मेंही सब कुछ है कंटेंट
के सिक्योरिटी के लिए जो भी कंटेंट है
उसकी सिक्योरिटी के लिए सीएसपी पॉलिसी जो
है वह लगाई जाती है ताकि जो पेज लोड हो
रहा है तो ब्राउजर को सर्वर इंस्ट्रक्ट कर
है कि आप यह पर्टिकुलर रूल के अकॉर्डिंग
ही पेज को लोड करो पेज में यह पर्टिकुलर
स्क्रिप्ट ही रन होंगी यह पर्टिकुलर इस
टाइप के इमेज सोर्स आईएमजी सोर्स टैग ही
यूज होंगे या इसी जगह से अगर स्क्रिप्ट
होगी तब लोड होगा नहीं तो नहीं होगा अब
देखो यहां पर इसका मतलब क्या
है इस फ्रेम इस सीएसपी का कि फ्रेम एंसेट
सेल्फ ठीक है सेल्फ का मतलब क्या होता है
मैं आपको बताता हूं सेल्फ का मतलब सिर्फ
खुद के ही से ओनली या कोई डोमेन अगर लगा
हु य पर तो खुद के डोमेन से बाकी सब जगह
को ब्लॉक कर दो बाकी सारी जो चीजें है
ब्लॉक करो स्क्रिप्ट वगैरह फ्रेम्स वगर जो
आ रही है वो ब्लॉक कर दो अब देखो इससे
रिलेटेड मैं तुमको एक चीज बता देता हूं यह
मैं पहले बताने वाला था बट मैं भूल गया इस
पर आ जाना वेब सिक्योरिटी अकेडमी प यहां
चले जाना व्यू ल टॉपिक्स
प ठीक
है क्या हुआ
भाई
कौन है कौन क्या गाली दे रहा है भाई कौन
गाली दे रहा है उतना ध्यान नहीं देता मैं
यार थैंक
यू आई डोंट नो बट ठीक है मैं देख लेता हूं
अगर कोई है अगर कोई ट्रबल कर रहा है प्लीज
आप चैट में आप लोग स्पैम मत कीजिए चैट में
यार डिस्टर्ब मत किया कीजिए इससे
डिस्टरबेंस हो जाती है क्लास की
राइट
ओके ठीक है मैं देख लेता हूं यहां पर हु
यू आर टॉकिंग
अबाउट कौन है भाई है क्रैकर कहीं कहां कुछ
तो दिखा नहीं मुझे है क्रैकर करके
कोई ओके आई थिंक शायद गर्वित ने हटा दिया
होगा मेरे खल से गवित है य पर तो बाकी ठीक
है चलो ठीक है चलो डिस्टर्ब मत क्या करो
यार अब
हां तो यहां जाना वेब सिक्योरिटी अकेडमी
पर
ऑल टॉपिक्स कर लेना नीचे आना यहां पे
क्लाइंट साइड में एक्सेसेस प आ जाना जब
तुम एक्सेसेस प आओगे तो यहां नीचे की तरफ
आओगे स्क्रॉल करोगे लेफ्ट साइड में तो
यहां पे कंटेंट सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी नाम की
एक टैब होगी कंटेंट सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी इस
पे आ जाना और इसको कंप्लीट थोड़ा सा अच्छे
से पढ़ लेना इसके लैब्स को सॉल्व कर लेना
ये लैब आपको दिख रही होगी रिफ्लेक्टेड
एक्सेसेस प्रोटेक्टेड बाय वेरी स्ट्रिक्ट
सीएसपी विथ डांगली मार्क अप अटैक तो ये आप
देख लीजिएगा बेसिकली क्या होता है इज अ
ब्राउजर सिक्योरिटी मैकेनिज्म दैट एम्स टू
मिटिगेट एक्सेसेस एंड सम अदर अटैक
इंजेक्शन अटैक्स की बा रही य इट वर्क्स बा
रिस्ट्रिक्टिंग द रिसोर्स स्क्रिप्ट और
इमेजेस कोट पेज कैन लोड एंड
रिस्ट्रिक्टिंग वेदर पेज कैन बी फ्रेम बाय
अदर पेजेस ठीक है तो यह वही चीज है यहां
पर जो आपको यहां पर दिख रही है ना यह
पॉलिसी फ्रेम एंसे तो यह वही बात है कि
दूसरा कोई फ्रेम कर सकता है कि नहीं उस
पेज को तो सेल्फ है तो सेल्फ सेल्फ सर्वर
के तरफ से ही होगा टू इनेबल अ सीएसपी
रिस्पांस नीड टू इंक्लूड एटीपी रिस्पांस
हेडर रिस्पांस हेडर का मतलब सर्वर हेडर
वाली जो बात है कांटेक्ट सिक्योरिटी
पॉलिसी विथ अ वैल्यू कंटेनिंग द पॉलिसी अब
इसमें जैसे ये स्क्रिप्ट एसआरसी नाम का एक
आपका स्क्रिप्ट एसआरसी नाम का एक टैग मतलब
एक वैल्यू है एक रूल है एंड यहां पे आपको
अगर सेल्फ लिखा आता है यहां पे इसका मतलब
है कि द फॉलोइंग डायरेक्टिव विल ओनली अलाउ
स्क्रिप्ट टू बी लोडेड फ्रॉम द सेम ओरिजिन
एज द पेज इट सेल्फ जो पेज जहां से ओरिजिन
हो रहा है पेज का जो ओरिजिन है बस उसी के
तरफ से आपका जो स्क्रिप्ट है वो लोड होगा
बाकी हर जगह से अगर कोई स्क्रिप्ट आ रही
है दैट वड न नॉट बी लोडिंग वो लोड आपका
नहीं होगा यह बात ध्यान में
रखिएगा ठीक है तो यह इस तरीके से सीएसपी
जो होती है वो अप्लाई की जाती है एंड यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे कि द फॉलोइंग
डायरेक्टरी विल ओनली स्क्रिप्ट फ्रॉम द अब
ये इस तरह से लगा स्क्रिप्ट एसआरसी
एचटीटीपीएस तो इस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट से या
डोमेन से ही कोई स्क्रिप्ट जो है वो अगर
लोड मतलब वो लोड होगी यहां पे इसके कहने
का मतलब यही है एंड बाकी जगह से ये जो है
वो ब्लॉक कर दी जाती है ठीक है अब इसको ना
दो तरी तरीके से किया जाता है नॉन्स और
हैशेज के फॉर्म में भी किया जाता है यहां
पे सीएसपी डायरेक्टिव कैन बी स्पेसिफाइड अ
नॉस रैंडम वैल्यू स्पेसिफाई कर दी जाती है
जो सीएसपी आपकी हेडर्स लगती है जैसे ये
हेडर है ना यहां पे ये सीएसपी कंटेंट
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी हेड है यहां पे यहां पे
एक नॉन्स वैल्यू ऐड कर दी जाती है एक
रैंडम वैल्यू जिसको हम बोलते हैं नॉन्स
वैल्यू को ठीक है एंड सेम वैल्यू मस्ट बी
यूज्ड इन द टैग दैट लोडस अ स्क्रिप्ट मतलब
आप जो टैग लोड कर रहे हो जो स्क्रिप्ट लोड
कर रहे हो उसकी सेम नॉन्स वैल्यू होनी
चाहिए अब या तुम तो कुछ भी स्क्रिप्ट वहां
पर चला रहे हो उसकी वैल्यू सेम कैसे हो
सकती है यानी कि वही स्क्रिप्ट लोड होंगी
जो सेम नॉन्स वैल्यू कंटेन करती है यानी
कि जो सर्वर के साइड से नॉन्स वैल्यू सेट
है वहां पे सीएसपी
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
एसपी से रिलेटेड एंड वो थोड़ा सा एडवांस
हो जाएगा अगर मैं अभी इस पॉइंट ऑफ टाइम पे
बात करूं उसकी तो उसको हम लेटर ऑन देखेंगे
ठीक है उसके लिए टेंशन नहीं लेना है बट
हां सीएसपी बायपास मैंने आपको एक टर्म दे
दिया है एंड मैंने आपको हमेशा बोला है कि
जब भी आप बग बाउंट करते हैं मेरे एक-एक
टर्म को एक-एक वर्ड को सुनिए और उसको
एक्सप्लोर किया कीजिए तो आपको सीएसपी एंड
सीएसपी बायपास इसको एक्सप्लोर करना है फॉर
एक्सएसएस आपको समझ में आ जाएगा कि मैं किस
बारे में बात कर रहा हूं क्योंकि अभी इस
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट के लिए बहुत सारे
बिगिनर्स यहां पे हैं वो थोड़ा सा बेकार
चीज हो जाता है थोड़ा डिफरेंट हो जाता है
थोड़ा एडवांस हो जाता है तो उसके तरफ अभी
नहीं जा रहे नहीं तो पता चले जो हम कर रहे
हैं वो भी नहीं कर पाएंगे और दिमाग से
आपके निकल जाएगा फिलहाल के लिए मैं आपको
बस एग्जांपल दे रहा हूं यहां पे इफ द
वैल्यू डज नॉट मैच स्क्रिप्ट विल नॉट
एग्जीक्यूट वैसे ही यहां पे सीएसपी
डायरेक्टिव कैन स्पेसिफाई अ हैश ठीक है ऑफ
द कंटेंट्स ऑफ द ट्रस्टेड
स्क्रिप्ट ठीक है इफ द हैश ऑफ द एक्चुअल
स्क्रिप्ट डज नॉट मैच द वैल्यू स्पेसिफाइड
इन द डायरेक्टरी देन द स्क्रिप्ट विल नॉट
एग्जीक्यूट मान लो तुमने एक स्क्रिप्ट लच
किया तुमने ने एक लाइक एक्सएसएस का पेलोड
लॉच किया वो पेलोड क्या है वो पेलोड ये
वाली पेलोड है मान लो ये
है लेट्स सपोज वो पेलोड है यहां पे वेयर
ऑन क्लिक अलर्ट टेस्ट वेयर अब ये पेलोड का
हैश जनरेट करोगे एंड वो हैश कभी भी मैच
नहीं करेगा जो हैश सेट है आपके सर्वर के
साइड से ओबवियसली कभी मैच नहीं करेगा
क्योंकि वह सेम होगा ही नहीं ना सिंपल सा
फंडा है वह सेम हो जरूरी नहीं है ना यार
सेम हो ऐसा जरूरी नहीं है तो वह बाईपास
होगा नहीं आपसे और वह स्क्रिप्ट रन नहीं
करेगी एज सिंपल एज दैट तो इस तरीके से आप
वो चीजें भी मतलब सीएसपी जो है वो
इंप्लीमेंट होता है ठीक है इट्स क्वाइट
कॉमन फॉर अ सीएसपी टू ब्लॉक रिसोर्सेस
लाइक स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट टैग को सिंपली
बहुत ज्यादा ब्लॉक करता है ये सीएसपी
मैकेनिज्म हाउ एवर मेनी सीएसपी डू अलाउ
इमेज रिक्वेस्ट्स इमेज रिक्वेस्ट को बहुत
सारे अलाउ कर देते हैं दिस मींस यू कैन
ऑफेन यूज आईएमजी एलिमेंट्स टू मेक
रिक्वेस्ट टू एक्सटर्नल सर्वर इन ऑर्डर टू
डिस्क्लोज मतलब आईएमजी एसआरसी टैक्स वाले
अगर आप यूज कर रहे हो ज्यादातर अपने पे
लोट्स को तो वहां पे चांसेस थोड़े आपके
इंक्रीज हो जाते हैं कहने का मतलब यह है
जैसे कौन सा मैं टैग की बात कर रहा हूं
मैं अगर यहां पे लिस्ट में चलता हूं
एक्सेस पेलोड्स में यहां पे मैं एक बात
करता हूं यहां पे इस
वाले पेलोड की आईएमजीएसआरसी की तो मैं
इसको यूज कर सकता हूं काइंड ऑफ इफ आई वांट
आई कैन यूटिलाइज दिस एवरी वेयर टू बाईपास
सम काइंड ऑफ सीएसपी सम काइंड ऑफ़ सीएसपी
जो कुछ सीएसपी जो इमेज लोडिंग अलाउ कर
देते हैं उसको हम यहां पे बाईपास कर सकते
हैं वहां पे हम यहां पे आईएमजीएसआरसी वाली
जो टैब है उसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं एंड वी
कैन ट्राई आउट कि हां यहां पे क्या हो रहा
है एंड यहां पे हम देख सकते हैं कंट्रोल f
में
प्रॉम्न यहां पे ऑब् वियस यहां पे जब हम
प्रोमट वाली चीज़ कर रहे हैं तो यहां पे
हमारा फिर से उसी तरीके से सेम चीज है तो
ओबवियसली हम इसको पहले से फिर से क्लोज
करके ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं एंड लेट्स
ट्राई आउट टी आई टी एल ई बट वही है यह
जरूरी नहीं है वल्नरेबल होगा ही हम इसको
क्लोज कर देते हैं एंड बाकी सारी चीजें हम
यहां पे कमेंट कर देते हैं एंड कॉपी कर
लेते हैं एंड लेट्स प्रेस एंटर की इफ इट
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हो रहा है कोई बात नहीं
हम इसको इनकोड कर लेंगे एंड अगेन वी विल
ट्राई आउट अगर यह होता है दैट वड बी ठीक
बेटर नहीं होता है दैट वड बी मच बेटर कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है तो इस तरीके से आप ट्राई
आउट कर सकते कहने का सेंस है यू कैन जस्ट
गिव इट अ ट्राई सिंपल
ओके ओके ठीक है चलिए अब हां देखो सीएसपी
और सीओ आरएस वगैरह जो है इसके लिए सेपरेट
क्लास मुझे लेनी पड़ेगी आपकी तभी जाक आपको
समझ में आएगा अगर आप चाहते हैं मैं
एक्सेसेस के अंदर उसको घुसा के आपको बता
दूं तो वह आपका ऊपर ऊपर वाला काम हो जाएगा
और मैं ऊपर और ऊपर ऊपर वाले क्लासेस नहीं
लेता कभी भी मेरे को ऊपर ऊपर वाले क्लासेस
लेके एंड फ्री क्लास की वैल्यू कम हो गई
या कम है कम होती है फ्री चीजें इसको
फ्लोरिश नहीं करने देना है बल्कि इसी के
तो अगेंस्ट काम करना है कि फ्री चीजों जो
होती है फ्री चीजें उसकी भी वैल्यू होती
है अगर आप अपना ध्यान देते हो तो तो उसके
ऊपर मैं अलग से क्लास ले लूंगा एक सीएसपी
बायपास सीएसपी सीएसपी बायपास एंड सीआरएस
जो है अ लाइक ये सारी चीजें आपको मैं लेकर
एक अलग से बना के और बढ़िया से एक्सप्लेन
करके समझा दूंगा ताकि आप उसको यूटिलाइज कर
पाए फर्द जो भी अटैक्स होते हैं सबके अंदर
में ठीक है एक्स फॉरवर्ड वाला भी कर दूंगा
आपका एक्स फ्रेम भी कर दूंगा सब चीज कर
दूंगा ठीक है चलिए तो ये आप एक बार देख
लीजिएगा यह जरूर से जरूर ध्यान दीजिएगा
चलिए
ओके ठीक
है त्रिलोक का कौन सा टूल है
यार त्रिलोक का कौन सा टूल है
यार एक्सस क्रॉलर बोल रही है तो एक्सस
क्रॉलर टू कोई अब यह टूल तो ऐसा कोई और
टूल है शायद एक्सेस स्क्रॉलर करके मुझे
कहीं मिल नहीं रहा
है गेट हब ट्राई कर सकते हैं बट आई एम नॉट
सीइंग एंड आपका कोई यूआरएल आ नहीं सकता
है शंकी करके कुछ था ना आपका तो यह भी
मैंने देख लिया कुछ कहीं पर है नहीं आपका
टूल एक बार नाम क्या दिया था आपने एक बार
नाम दे दीजिए एक बार नाम फिर से दे दीजिए
मैं एक बार नाम फिर से चेक कर लेता हूं
आपका नाम कुछ आपने दिया था
ना ओके
संकी सिक्योरिटी ओके
स संकी
सिक्योरिटी गिट हब लेट्स सी आई थिंक यह है
क्या आई डाउट कि यही
है शायद यह तो नहीं है मुझे यह तो नहीं लग
रहा संकी सिक्योरिटी
एक्सेस
क्रॉलर मैं यहां पर हाइ फन दे देता हूं यह
एक एक किसी का यह
लाइक टूल है बट मुझे कहीं मिल नहीं रहा है
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी मुझे आपका टूल मिल नहीं
रहा है शंकी एक्सस स्क्रॉलर वाली ठीक है
नहीं नहीं वो टूल मैं चेक नहीं कर रहा मैं
टूल के लिए नहीं कर रहा वो एक बंदा है
जिसका एक टूल था शंकी करके कुछ उसका टूल
मिल नहीं रहा है उसने बोला था सर मुझे इस
टूल का वो करो मेरे टूल का देखो हो आप तो
मुझे आपका टूल नहीं मिल रहा है तो आप मुझे
क्या कीजिएगा अ एक बार हमारा जो डिफर
अकेडमी एंड पप है उसपे अगर आप फ्री कोर्स
में है तो वहां पे आप चैट में लिंक भेज
दीजिएगा ठीक है वो मैं चेक आउट कर लूंगा
आपका ओके चलिए अब हम यहां पे एक टारगेट
लेते हैं एंड उसपे हम ट्राई आउट करते हैं
व विल ट्राई आउट राइट तो हमें यहां पे मिल
चुका है सारा पेलोड हमने चेक कर लिया है
बहुत अच्छी बात है एंड लेंथ में अगर हम
चलेंगे तो लेंथ बहुत ही हाई हमारी यह वाली
एक लेंथ आ रही है अ ये लेंथ आ रही है तो
इसको हम कॉपी सो रिस्पांस ब्राउजर कर
लेंगे कॉपी कर लेंगे टुडे इज माय फर्स्ट
क्लास ग्रेट आप पहले के क्लासेस को भी अ
कंप्लीट कीजिएगा जरूर से जरूर
चलिए सो
दैट्ची क फॉर
अनदर टारगेट तो हम अब यहां से टारगेट
लेंगे ठीक है कोई एक टारगेट यहां से लेंगे
लेट्स सी अ लेट्स चेक दे टारगेट
अ सेबे उ यह क्या है कौन सा टारगेट है ये
रिचार्ड चर्च वेब डिजाइन अ ठीक है
अ ये हमारा टारगेट है एक कोई
है बेरियन बाइबल सोसाइटी ओज सो लेट्स ओपन
दिस या सो ये टारगेट को हम ले लेते हैं
बाइबल सोसाइटी करके यहां पे है बेरियन
बाइबल
सोसाइटी सो वी कैन टेक दिस एज अ टारगेट
एंड हम बाकी चीजें क्लोज कर देते हैं
टार्गेट पर जाते हैं एंड यहां पे हम इन सो
इन स्कोप आइटम्स हटा देते हैं फिलहाल के
लिए एंड दिस इज आवर टारगेट राइट यहां पे
सर्च
फंक्शनालिस वी कैन डू वन थिंग हम इसको
स्कोप में ऐड कर देते हैं लेट्स पुट इट ऑन
स्कोप सो वयर इट
इज कहां गया
भैया
कहीं मुझे दिख क्यों नहीं रही है ये
टारगेट ओके रि इनेबल कर देते हैं
इसको शायद अब ये दिख जाएगी मे बी मे
बी यस आ चुके यहां पे बबन बाइबल सटी ओजी
इसको हम ऐड टू स्कोप कर देते हैं एंड यहां
से हम स्कोप आइटम्स ओनली व्यू कर लेते हैं
एंड चलिए बहुत बढ़िया यहां पे ठीक है अब
यहां पे हम ड स्पाइडर दिस होस्ट पे क्लिक
कर देते हैं लेट्स क्रॉल एवरी यूआरएल
स्पाइडर कर लेते हैं यहां पे होस्ट को
लेट्स सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग सम स्टेटसे तो
हम यहां पे पैरामीटर तो मिल रहे है यहां
पे स्टेटस देख लेते हैं एंड पैरामीटर्स के
साथ स्टेटस देख लेते हैं ओके इट्स
डब्ल्यूपी ओके सो आई थिंक दिस इज ऑन
वर्डप्रेस ओके ये वर्डप्रेस के ऊपर है
सो ठीक है चलो देख लेते हैं दे लेस चांसेस
वैसे तो बाकी कुछ और भी देख सकते हैं कुछ
और अगर मिलता है तो यहां पर
एक यहां पर हमें एक पैरामीटर मिला है बट ए
दिस दिस पैरामीटर आल्सो बट नॉट वर्किंग
ठीक है इसको हम नहीं रखते य पर नहीं
रखेंगे इसको जस्ट रिमूव करते हैं इसको
रिमूव कर देते यरल को दिस इ ऑन वर्डप्रेस
जस्ट रिमूविंग
इट ट्स इट तो चलिए यहां पर हम एक और
कोई टगे यूज करेंगे जो वर्डप्रेस प
बेसिकली ना हो ट वुड बी मच बेटर ठीक
है लेट्स चेक लेट्स चेक लेट्स चेक चलिए यह
वाला कैसा टारगेट है लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
दिस टारगेट जी एल एटी ए ए कॉ कुछ करके
यहां
पे
ओ यह कौन सा लैंग्वेज है
भाई य अजब सा लैंग्वेज है यहां पर स्पेनिश
लैंग्वेज है
सो आप चेक कर सकते हो इसको कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है अगर आप चाहो तो चेक कर सकते हो
इसी का दूसरा एक वेबसाइट है यह भी वपस प
है क्या लेट्स सी लेट्स ओपन
इट ओके से कप्स कॉ लेट्स
ओपन से कपस कॉ यहां पर है फिक्स्ड वाले जो
है बीच के हैं यहां पे तो फिक्स 7 c.com प
चलते हैं यहां पे लेट्स सी व्ट इज से
c.com क्या है भैया ये
ओके कोर्स काउंसलर एंड ऑल थेरेपी पता नहीं
कुछ कुछ ऐसी कुछ चीजें है चलिए अच्छी बात
है यहां पे यहां पे इफ वी आर गेटिंग
एनीथिंग हमें यहां प सर्च फॉर्म नहीं भी आ
रहा है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हमें सर्च
फॉर्म से मतलब नहीं है हमें पैरामीटर से
मतलब होना चाहिए तो वी आर सर्चिंग फॉर
पैरामीटर राइट सो हमें पैरामीटर
चाहिए सो वी आर हियर एंड लेट्स सी हमारे
पास यहां पर सेवन कप्स आ चुके हैं होंगे
शायद लेट्स सी र सेन कप्स यह रही से कप्स
कॉ आ चुका
है चलिए बहुत
बढ़िया हा जी यही है हमारा से c.com इसको
हम टारगेट स्कोप में ऐड कर देते हैं एंड
यहां पर हम शो इन स्कोप आइटम्स कर देते
हैं से कप्स आ चुके हैं हमारे पास एंड
इसको हम स्पाइडर कर देते हैं ठीक है सो
लेट्स स्पाइडर दिस एंड आई होप कि दिस इज
नॉट ऑन वर्डप्रेस या चलिए बढ़िया तो हमने
यहां प स्पाइडर कर दिया है एंड वी आर
गोइंग वी आर गेटिंग एंड स्पाइडरिंग जो है
इनेबल हो चुकी है स्पाइडरिंग काम कर रही
है सो लेट्स वेट फॉर इट टू
कंप्लीट क्या हुआ भैया कोई दिक्कत आ रही
है क्या किसी को मजा आ रहा है कि नहीं लिए
तो बता दो आर यू एंजॉयिंग
मजा आ रहा है भाई सबको मजा आ रहा है कि
नहीं आ रहा है
इंटरेस्टिंग सर आर ऑटोमेशन टूल्स
प्रोहिबिटेड इन द रिस्पांसिबल
डिस्क्लोजर
बिकॉज बब शूट वगर यूज कर सकते हो यार बब
शूट के लिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है भाई बब शूट
वगर आराम से यूज कर सकते
हो बब
शूट कर सकते हो ठीक है प्लीज डोंट स्पैम
बब शूट यूज
कीजिए तो यहां पर हो रहा है लव फ्रॉम
जोधपुर लव फ्रॉम जोधपुर ओके ओके ब्रदर ल
फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रदर एंजॉय च ये अच्छी बात है आपकी आपकी
लाइफ में प्रेजेंस भी अच्छी है आप लोगों
की
[संगीत]
दैट्ची सीएसआरएफ ठीक है यहां पर टेंप्लेट
क्या पैरामीटर है भैया यहां पे वर्जन एक
पैरामीटर है वर्जन पैरामीटर है तो आप
वर्जन पैरामीटर प भी आप चेक आउट कर सकते
हैं याद रखिएगा कुछ भी पैरामीटर हो यू कैन
चेक आउट ऑन द पैरामीटर कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
यहां पे ब्रेकअप स्टिल आ व्ट ये क्या है
ठीक है यह भी एक पैरामीटर है p = 2 तो हम
कोई से भी पैरामीटर पर चेक आउट कर सकते
हैं चलिए इस वाले को हम सेंड टू इंट्रूडर
कर देते
हैं पोजीशंस प चलते हैं यहां पे बाकी सारे
पोजीशंस कोई काम के नहीं है क्लियर कर
देते हैं हमारा एक पो
यह वाला जो पोजीशन है प इटू वाला इसको हम
सेलेक्ट करते हैं यहां पर पोजीशन ड कर
देते हैं पलो पर चलते हैं लोड करते हैं हम
अपने स्क्रिप्ट को यहां पर लोड कर देते
हैं यहां पर
हम ओपन कर देते हैं हमने ओपन किया य पर
सारे स्क्रिप्ट आ चुके हैं य पर स्टार्ट
टक पर क्लिक कर देंगे एंड लेट सी वट इ
हैपनिंग सो ट
स्टार्टेड क्या बात है यहां पे चला रहे
हैं चला रहे हैं यहां पर लेंथ जो है पहली
वह है 11000 की लेंथ है भैया पहली लेंथ
11000 से बड़ी लेंथ चाहिए कुछ है क्या कुछ
नहीं है 11000 से तो बड़ी लेंथ ही नहीं आई
है एक य आई है नॉर्मल सा शो रिस्पांस
ब्राउजर इसकी लेंथ कम है तो देखते हैं इट
शुड नॉट वर्क
ओबवियसली
या सो या इट्स नॉट
वर्किंग यहां पर वाली फॉर्म जो है इस पर
काम कर रहे हैं हम बेसिकली इसको मैनुअली
भी तब तक चेक आउट कर सकते हैं लाइक जो भी
आपका पेलोड है
स्क्रिप्ट
अलर्ट
एंड डि
फोनिक्स क्रिप्ट ठीक है य आप डाल के एंटर
कर सकते हैं एंड यू कैन सी फॉर इट लाइक
कुछ रिफ्लेक्शन है क्या डि फोनिक्स का सो
या इट्स रिफ्लेक्टिंग एंड
एंड यह वही बात है इट्स गेटिंग ट्रंकड एंड
यहां पर आपका स्क्रिप्ट ओके यहां पर आपका
जो ओके य ग्रेटर दन लेसन वाली जो चीज है
वह
आपकी ट्रंक हो रही
है ट्स ग्रेट सो लेट्स सी लेट्स सी व्ट वी
आर गोइंग टू
गेट सो हम यहां पर एक बार देख लेते
हैं लेट सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग कुछ हमें मिला क्या वी आर नॉट
गेटिंग एनीथिंग
नो ऑन माउस ओवर वाला चेक आउट कर सकते हैं
एक बार शो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर क्योंकि
हमारा गेटर लेस अगर फिल्टर आउट हो रहा है
सो वी कैन सी ऑन माउस ओवर पर कुछ है क्या
ये नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग
कहीं यहीं पर होना चाहिए बट नथिंग देर
राइट सो इट्स नॉट वर्किंग तो हमें यहां पर
लेंथ ज्यादा चाहिए ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
लेंथ ज्यादा हो गया आपका टाइम लेट हो गया
तो कोई बात नहीं कोई टेंशन मत लो इतना बट
टाइम प आया करो ज्यादा मजा आता
है
लेट्स ओपन ट्राई हैक
मी यहां पर एक बार एक्सस वाले पर चलते
हैं लेट्स गो टू द
एक्सस क्रॉस यह वाली लब आई होप आप सबने
सॉल्व की होगी एंड जैसा कि मैंने आपको
बताया था कि आपको करना है सॉल्व राइट तो
आई होप सो कि आपने की होगी यह चीज यहां से
हम एक पेलोड उठाएंगे ी विल जस्ट पुट
दिस पेलोड व विल ट्राई आउट यर एक बार
ट्राई करेंगे पेलोड
ओके ओके फिल्टरिंग दिस आल्सो काइंड ऑफ ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं कोई चलेगा ये तो यह भी आप
कर लीजिएगा यह जरूर से आप पूरा कीजिएगा
एंड पॉली ग्लोट्स वी कैन यूज बट यह काम
करेगा यहां पे जरूरी नहीं है हर पॉली गोट
हर जगह काम करे तो दिस इज सिंपली फॉर
बिडेन तो यहां प ये फॉर बिडेन आ रहा है
पॉली गल जो हमने यूज किया पॉली ग्लोट के
लिए तो इट इज कमिंग फर फॉर बिडेन सो दिस
काइंड ऑफ बिहेवियर वी कैन अजूम कि हमारे
पास आ सकता है पॉली गड के केस में राइट तो
कुछ ना कुछ है वहां पे बट स्टिल लेट्स सी
सो हमारे पास यहां पर लेंथ देख लेते हैं
यहां पे लेंथ कुछ बड़ा आया क्या कुछ लेंथ
बड़ा नहीं आ रहा हमारे पास सेम लेंथ आ रही
है राइट यस पेड
है ठीक
है एक्सेसेस के लिए बड़े टारगेट को अभी
चूज मत करो छोटे टारगेट के लिए ही जाओ तो
यहां पे हमें कुछ यहां प फिलहाल तो हमें
यहां पे चल रहा है य प नहीं मिल रहा है
यहां पे हम कोई और भी पैरामीटर के लिए चेक
आउट कर सकते हैं जैसे लेट्स गो टू सम अदर
पैरामीटर ब्रेकअप्स का है यहां पे ऑनलाइन
थेरेपी यहां पे है करके ठीक है ऑनलाइन
थेरेपी वाली है सेंड टू इंट्रूडर इंट्रूडर
प चलते हैं यहां पे पोजीशंस प चलते हैं
यहां क्लियर कर देते हैं एंड यहां पे एक
काम करते हैं आईडी थेरेपिस्ट आईडी करके
पैरामीटर है लेट्स पुट ऑन दिस अंडर ड
लेट्स गो टू द पेलोड लेट्स लोड एंड दिस
टाइम लेट्स लोड द पेलोड फ्रॉम बग बांटी
फोल्डर एंड यहां पर पेलोड टू है इसको ओपन
कर लेते हैं कितने पेलोड्स है टोटल 6500
बढ़िया इसको स्टार्ट कर देते हैं तो इसको
भी स्टार्ट कर देते हैं
चलिए सो हमने यहां पर इसको भी स्टार्ट कर
दिया है 5737 इज द लेंथ वी आर गेटिंग यर
लेट्स सी व्ट एल्स वी आर गोइंग टू
गेट तो यहां पर दो हमारे रन हो रहे
हैं एक हमारा यह रन हो रहा है एक हमारा यह
रन हो रहा है सो दो अटैक्स रन हो रहे हैं
कंकूट वली एक 6207 पेट्स के साथ हो रही है
एक 6500 पेट् के साथ हो रही है सो इफ वी
कैन गेट समथिंग लेट
पेड है तो ट्राई हकमी के वाउचर्स ले लो ना
यार कहीं ना कहीं से तुम्हें मैं कितनी
हिंट दूं तुम्हें कहीं ना कहीं से तुम्हें
मिल जाएंगे सस्ते में वो ले लो
भाई ठीक है ट्राई तो करो टेलीग्राम
पे हमने बोला था हम प्रोवाइड कर देंगे बट
चीपर बट हमारे पास अवेलेबल नहीं है तो ड
स्टॉक है
ओके सो यहां पर लेंथ में देखते हैं कुछ
हमें मिला क्या र नॉट गेटिंग य य लेथ में
57000 के अलावा
154 कुछ नहीं मिला यह एक मिला हमें बट शो
रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर लेट्स सी इफ वी आर
गेटिंग
समथिंग
ओके क्या है
यह कुछ भी थेरेपी थेरेपी चलो भाई कुछ भी
थेरेपी कर देते
हैं कुछ
कुछ नहीं मिला हमें यहां
पर
ओके डेट ऑफ बर्थ में टिंग चुंग टी टिंग ज
टी टिंग ज टिंग कुछ भी कर लो ईमेल आईडी
देनी है यहां पे यह पता नहीं क्या है यह
पासवर्ड है एंड यह यूजर नेम
है सो यू कैन गिव द यूजर नेम व्हाट एवर
यूजर नेम यू वांट तो मैं यहां पर पेलो डाल
देता हूं यहां ईमेल आईडी डाल देता हूं
हेलो
लोड कॉ पासवर्ड कुछ भी डाल देता हूं एंड
लेट्स
सी इफ इट
इज प्रोवाइड नो इट्स नॉट गेटिंग इट्स
नॉट स्क्रीन नेम मस्ट बी कंटे तो ये यहां
प फिल्टर आउट हो रहा है ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं यहां पे सो करेंटली वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
एनीथिंग आउट ऑफ दिस हमें कुछ यहां पे मिला
नहीं है ना
57500 यह बॉडी ऑन स्क्रोल आया एक शो स्नस
ब्राउजर कॉपी इसको पूरा स्कैन करना है याद
रखिएगा हार नहीं मारना है स्टार्टिंग में
ही पूरा स्कैन करना है
आपको पूरा स्कैन करके
आपको लाइक रिजल्ट्स चेक आउट करने है ठीक
है पूरा ही रिजल्ट चेक आउट करनी है देन ये
देखिए यहां पर ऑनलाइन थेरेपी रिटायर्ड वन
ठीक है ओके यहां पर कुछ मिला हमें एक लाख
से ऊपर कुछ नहीं है यहां पे सो इट्स नॉट
करट आई डोंट थिंक सो इट विल वर्क तो इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं मैं एंड यहां पर अगर
कुछ मिलता है तो हम देख सकते हैं 57
नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग या सो लेट्स क्लोज इट
चलो इसको भी पोजीशंस को क्लोज कर देते
हैं वी कैन मूव ऑन टू सम अदर
टारगेट ये कर देते
हैं चलिए तो हम एक और टारगेट प चलते हैं
एंड लेट्स हंट यह लैब जरूर सॉल्व कर
लीजिएगा आप सबसे रिक्वेस्ट है क्रॉस साट
स्क्रिप्टिंग के एंड वेब सिक्योरिटी
अकेडमी की जो आपकी लैब है जो मैंने आपको
बताई वो भी आपको कंपट करना है ठीक है चलिए
हम एक और टारगेट यूज करते हैं चूज करते
हैं टू पे चलते हैं यहां पे लेट्स गो टू द
टू लेट्स सिलेक्ट अ
टारगेट फ्रांस की कोई एक टारगेट है एफ आर
सो लेट्स ओपन दिस यूआरएल
फ्रांस कहां से क्लास स्टार्ट करू भैया
जीरो
से जीरो से स्टार्ट कीजिए सो दिस इज इमेज
सर्च समथिंग काइंड ऑफ
थिंग तो यह अच्छी बात
है तो हम इसको एज अ टार्गेट ले सकते हैं
सो लेट्स लोड दिस टारगेट ट इज रोज वायलेट
फ्रांस लेट्स सी वेर इट इज
कमिंग रोजर वायलेट रोज वायलेट कहां है
भैया रोज वायलेट
आपके
यह रहा रोज वालेट यह वाली हमारी जो है ड
टू स्कोप कर देते हैं एंड यहां पर उन
स्कोप आइटम्स कर लेते
हैं ताकि हमारा सिर्फ एक सिंगल डोमेन रोज
वालेट आ जाए यहां पे स्कोप में से सेवन
कप्स को वी कैन रिमूव वी कैन रिमूव अरे
भैया बस यार रिमूव कर देते हैं साइड मैप प
चलते हैं यहां पर हम इसको स्पाइडर कर लेते
हैं लेट्स सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग सम
पैरामीटर्स सो यस वी आर गोइंग गेटिंग
गेटिंग एंड इ दिस वर्डप्रेस नो नो नो नो
नो नो नो नो नो नो चलिए यहां पे चल देते
हैं सबमिट कर दो भाई कोई बात नहीं यहां पे
सबमिट कर देते हैं यहां पे लेट्स सी यस सो
वी आर गेटिंग सम पैरामीटर्स हियर सम
इंटरेस्टिंग पैरामीटर्स एक्चुअली लैंग्वेज
इंग्लिश यहां पे कुकीज इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पे
ओके यहां पे आते हैं लैंग्वेज इंग्लिश ठीक
है लैंग्वेज फ्रांस एंड दिस इ वर्जन यस
वेंजर लॉग इन लगन पीएपी प इ होड पीएपी ठीक
है
बढ़िया दिस इज समथिंग एस एस
ओके
ओके रिसर्च पेज यहां पर आ रहा है पेज वन
पेज टू आ रहा है ठीक है
बढ़िया ओके देर आर
मल्टीपल पैरामीटर्स वी आर गोइंग टू गेट
राइट नाउ
या तो चलिए यहां पे कोई सा भी एक दे लेते
हैं पैरामीटर लेते हैं प इ टू ये वाला देख
लेते हैं लॉगइन ड पीएपी वाली इसको कर देते
सेंड टू इंट्रूडर इंट्रूडर प चलते हैं
यहां पे यहां पोजीशन प चलते हैं यहां पे
एंड इसको हम कर देते हैं क्लियर कोई से भी
पोजीशंस पे आप कर सकते हो याद रखिएगा य
हमने किया क्लियर य हमने किया ऐड ऐड किया
यहां गए पेलोड्स पे यहां लोड पे एंड यहां
हम अपने पेलोड को लोड कर देते हैं ओपन कर
लेते हैं यहां शायद 14 तो समथिंग कम कम ही
पेलोड है तो इसको स्टार्ट अटैक कर देते
हैं एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग सो द
फर्स्ट लेंथ इज
36864 एंड बाकी 403 403 आ रहे हैं 200 नाम
की कोई चीज यहां पे हमें दिख नहीं रही है
फिलहाल के लिए सो एक 200 ये आया है 37000
ये आईएमजीएसआरसी ऑन एरर आ रहा है यहां पे
सो रिस्पांस इन ब्राउजर कॉपी किया यहां पे
लेट्स ट्राई आउट लेट्स ट
ऑन ओके ओके इज देर समथिंग कुछ भी नहीं है
यहां पे क्रिएट अकाउंट का ऑप्शन है ओके वी
आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग बहुत बड़ी यहां पे
आपको
अ पेज मिल रही है रीलोड किया हमने कुछ
हमें मिला नहीं यहां पे ठीक है कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है और भी चेक कर लेते
हैं 37000 का एक यह वाला मिला है एक ऑन
लोड भी मिला हमें तो शो रिस्पांस इन
ब्राउजर कर लेते हैं लेट्स ट्राई इट
आउट इफ वी आर गेटिंग एनी पॉप अप पॉप अप
पॉप अप पॉप अप नहीं मिला इसको चेक कर लेते
हैं सो रिपस इन ब्राउजर क्योंकि बहुत कमी
200 वाले हमें मिले पेलोड जिसकी लेंथ भी
ज्यादा है थोड़ी सी तो वी कैन चेक
इंडिविजुअली
राइट करेक्ट टीएम का लर्निंग पाथ यही है
कि जैसा मैं बताऊ वैसा करते जाओ
बस सो आई एमजी एसआरसी हमने ट्राई कर लिया
है हमें और कुछ नहीं मिला यहां पे लेट्स
सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग
समथिंग तो हम देख लेते हैं
य
ओके
लेट टोटल 1400 पेलो है यह तो हमें देखना
है कितने पेलो तक क्या आ रहे है
य
ओके लाइक ठोक दिया सबने क्या सबने लाइक
ठोक है क्या मुझे लगता लाइक तो ठोक दिया
सबने विंड 10 11 भाई कोई सा भी यूज कर लो
मैं तो 11 यूज कर रहा हूं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है कोई सा भी यूज करो यार कोई टेंशन इतना
टेंशन क्यों लेना है भाई लाइफ में लाइफ
में टेंशन लेने वि 101 दोनों सही है
जिंदगी को बिंदास दिया करो यार 101 के
चक्कर में मत पड़ो तो एक तो ये चीज हो गई
चलो ये तो हो रही स्कैन इसको हमन देते हैं
अब तुम क्या कर सकते हो ना हर एक ऑप्शन को
हर एक चीज को ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो ठीक है
अब जैसे
देखो ये तो हमारा हो रहा है चलिए अच्छी
बात है आप क्रिएट अकाउंट पे क्लिक कर रहे
हैं ना तो आपको क्रिएट अकाउंट करना है
यहां पे ठीक है तो हम यहां पे चलो टेंप
मेल का यूज कर लेते
हैं यहां फर्स्ट नेम डालता हूं मैं फर्स्ट
नेम में मैं अपना एक फर्स्ट नेम में मैं
अपना एक यूज कर लूंगा पेलोड फर्स्ट नेम
में डाल देते हैं लास्ट नेम में भी पेलोड
डाल देते हैं ईमेल एड्रेस जो है हम यह
यहां से डिस्पोजेबल यूज करेंगे ताकि ईमेल
एड्रेस हमारा वैलिड लगे फोन नंबर जो है हम
ओबवियसली कंट्री इंडिया सेलेक्ट कर लेते
हैं इंडिया है क्या बहुत बढ़िया फोन नंबर
डाल देते
हैं फोन नंबर भी हम सही डाल देते हैं
पासवर्ड में हम सही डालेंगे तो पासवर्ड
में हम य पर डाल देते
हैं हमने डाल दिया
पासवर्ड ओके सो हमने फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम
में पेलोड यूज किया अपना एंड आर यू
प्रोफेशनल अरे भाई तो
प्रोफेशनल क्यों यार आई अग्री कर देते हैं
एंड प्रोफेशनल वाली फील्ड भरनी जरूरी है
क्या चल देख लेते हैं क्रिएट
अकाउंट
नेवर ओके लेट्स
सी
इफ वी आर गेटिंग समथिंग नो हमें लगता है
यह डालना पड़ेगा तो मैं य डाल देता हूं
रोनिक्स पोजीशंस में यहां पर ऐड कर देता
हूं
मैं
डायरेक्टर सीईओ बिजनेस सेक्टर में यहां पर
हम डाल देते हैं ववर कुछ भी डाल देते हैं
टीचिंग रिसर्च एड्रेस में डाल देते हैं
न्यू
दिल्ली ठीक है एड्रेस में भी आप पेलो डाल
सकते हो यू डोंट नीड टू एंटर न्यू दिल्ली
और समथिंग लाइक दैट जस्ट एटर पेलोड जो
आपका पेलोड है वो डाल दो एड्रेस में जो भी
फील्ड है एड्रेस कंटिन्यूड में भी डाल दो
कंटिन्यूड में भी डाल दो सिटी में आप न्यू
दिल्ली डाल दो जिप कोड में सही डाल देते
हैं बाकी सब चीजें सही है सो
दैट्ची धन्यवाद भाई धन्यवाद धन्यवाद चलिए
यहां पे ये हाईलाइट तो नहीं हो रहा है
इसका मतलब है देयर इज समथिंग दैट नीड्स टू
बी चेंज्ड एंड ये चेंज जो है वो क्या करना
होगा हमें तो शायद फर्स्ट
नेम तो सही है लास्ट नेम सब कुछ सही है सो
लेट्स डू वन थिंग लेट्स रिमूव
इट ओके यह तो पहले ही हमारा अन हाईलाइट हो
चुका था बार रिसेंट करते हैं यहां पर
क्रिएट अकाउंट करते हैं फर्स्ट नेम में हम
क्या कर देते हैं हम सारी चीज एक बार फिल
आउट कर ही देते हैं मा डाल देते हैं यह
डाल दिया हमने ईमेल एड्रेस में हमने ये टम
मेल डाल
दिया टम मेल जिंदाबाद है भाई सही
कंट्री इंडिया डाल दिया फोन नंबर में
हमने फोन नंबर डाल दिया पासवर्ड में
हमने पासवर्ड हमने डाल
दिया कंपनी में हमने कंपनी डाल दी पोजीशन
हमने पोजीशन डाल दिया बिजनेस सेक्टर कुछ
भी डाल दो अभी के लिए तो एड्रेस एड्रेस
एड्रेस
तो एड्रेस में हमने पेलो डाल दिया आई थिंक
इफ वी कैन गो विद दैट न्यू
दिल्ली देन यहां पे 45401 डाल दी अरे यह
क्या डाल रहा मैं डेली का डालना है ना
मुझे डेली का डाल दिया अग्री कर दिया
क्रिएट अकाउंट लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग
कुछ होता ही नहीं होता है कुछ हो नहीं रहा
मेरे ख्याल
से तो या आर यी गेटिंग एनी ईमेल नो वी आर
नॉट गेटिंग ईमेल सो या दिस दिस इज
ब्लॉकिंग यह ब्लॉक कर रहे हैं सिंपल सा
फंडा है यहां पे जो हमने पेलोड यूज किया
है बेसिकली तो दे आर ब्लॉकिंग और कुछ भी
नहीं है यहां पे तो मैं यहां पे एड्रेस
में न्यू डेली डाल देता हूं अब तो शायद ये
ये एक्सेप्ट नहीं करेंगे मतलब आपको यहां
पे लॉगइन करना था लॉग इन करके आप हर एक
फंक्शनैलिटी को चेक आउट कर सकते हैं एंड
यहां पे ओबवियसली यह फॉर बिडेन आ रहा है
शायद मेरे ख्याल से
अ ओके यह यहां का
था ठीक है तो एक बार हम अपने पलट प आ जाते
हैं यहां फिनिश हो चुका है 37 चलिए लेंथ
देख लेते
इफ वी आर गेटिंग समथिंग हमें कुछ ऐसा कुछ
खास मिला नहीं है तीन थे हमने तीन चेक कर
लिए एंड ट्स इट आप अलग अलग पलट के लिए फिर
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो चेक आउट कर सकते हो
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक है अब यहां पर
देखो मैं एक चीज बताता हूं जैसे कि तुमने
क्या किया कोई भी टारगेट तुमने चूज कर ली
ठीक है व्ट एवर टारगेट यू आर चूसिंग उससे
मतलब नहीं है जैसे हमने क्या किया हम यहां
पर गए ओपन बग बाउंटीज पर
गए मैं आपको माइंड सेट बताता हूं थोड़ा सा
समझा देता
हूं ठीक है एंड हमने यहां पर ये एक है माई
माई करके कुछ पता नहीं क्या टारगेट है
यार तो इस टारगेट को हमने ओपन कर
लिया सब्सक्राइब डोनेट वगैरह जो भी है य
इस टारगेट को हमने कॉपी कर लिया इस टारगेट
को हमने यहां पर पेस्ट कर लिया ठीक
है
ममीज कॉ करके है कुछ भी यहां पर अब यहां
पर कोई लॉगिन फंक्शन है अगर तो लॉगइन
फंक्शन को आप यूज कीजिएगा नहीं है तो कोई
बात नहीं आप छोड़ सकते हैं बा अगर है तो
उसको जरूर यूज कीजिएगा फिलहाल नहीं है
यहां पे तो हम यहां पे सिंपल
सा
स्क्रिप्ट
अलर्ट यहां पे डि फ्रक्स यूज
करेंगे एंड यहां स्क्रिप्ट टैग को क्लोज
करेंगे एंड यहां पर हम एंटर मार देंगे
लेट्स सी इफ इट इज रिफ्लेक्टिंग
समथिंग ठीक है कंट्रोल यू करेंगे यहां पे
कंट्रोल एफ करेंगे एंड डिफ्रॉक सर्च
करेंगे सो या इट से इट इज अ लाइक बेसिकली
ये एक डोम के अंदर हमारा जो कीवर्ड है
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है इस तरीके से अ
स्क्रिप्ट एंड दैट इज ट्र ट्रंकटिंग आवर
एवरीथिंग जो भी हमारा अ जो हमारा कीवर्ड
है उसको ट्रंक किया जा रहा है सिंपल सा
फंडा है यहां पे तो इसको हम एज अ इनकोड
वगैरह करके भी ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो इफ यू
वांट जस्ट इनकोड इट डबल इनकोड इट इफ यू
वांट एंड देन ट्राई आउट हियर एंड प्रेस
एंटर की लेट्स सी इफ यू आर गेटिंग समथिंग
नहीं कुछ मिल रहा है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
यहां पे आप पर्टिकुलर क्या कर सकते हैं
यहां पे डबल इनकोडिंग जो किया है इसके
साथ-साथ
आप डिकोड डिकोड यहां पे आप इसको कमेंट आउट
भी कर दीजिए एंड देन आप इसको इनकोड कर
दीजिए देन आप इसको ट्राई आउट कर लीजिए ठीक
है तो ये तो एक तरीका हो गया एक आप बप शूट
से ट्राई आउट कर ही सकते हैं कुछ इफ वी आर
गेटिंग समथिंग तो नॉट सो हम इसको फीचर इल
ओ इट सर्च एंड पैरामीटर ये ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं एक ये टारगेट हो गया इस तरीके का
दूसरा टारगेट हम कैसा ले सकते हैं जहां पे
हमें कोई फंक्शनैलिटी मिलता हो साइन इन
साइन अप वगैरह का वो भी ट्राई कर सकते
स्टार ब्रॉडकास्ट है यहां पर एंड दिस इ
टवा ड
ओजी लेटस ा
ट सस इ नॉट
टारगेट लेट्स सी दिस वन इसको ट करते
हैं हां ये ठीक है ड सीड आओ जो भी है यह
अच्छा टारगेट लग रहा है मुझे मुझे यहां पर
लॉगइन साइन अप का ऑप्शन दिख रहा है तो
मेरे लिए यह बेहतरीन टारगेट हो सकता है तो
मैं इसको ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड यहां पे
साइन इन का ऑप्शन हो रहा है साइन इन का
ऑप्शन तो साइन अप का ऑप्शन भी हो ही ग
शायद नॉलेज बेस पार्टनर साइन अप करते हैं
डड ठीक है रजिस्टर एंड अकाउंट का क्क
अकाउंट का हमें एक मस्त ऑप्शन मिल रहा है
बिजनेस ईमेल का यूज करके हमें यह मिल रहा
है करने का तो हम बिजनेस ईमेल यूज कर
लेंगे कोई दिक्कत अभी नहीं है तो हम ऑन
करते हैं यहां पे एंड अब यहां पे ऑप्शंस आ
रहे हैं व्ट योर बिजनेस कॉल्ड तो मैं करता
हूं
डेनिक्स ईमेल एड्रेस करते हैं यहां पे तो
मैं यहां प कर देता हूं हेलो @ de.com
ईमेल आईडी हमने डाल दी पासवर्ड यहां डाल
रहे हैं
तो पासवर्ड हमने डाल दिया यहां पे
चलो हमने पासवर्ड डाल दिया कंटिन्यू कर
देते हैं यहां पे लेट्स चेक ड कै ट
टेंपररी और अनवेरीफाइड सिंस वी सेंड अ वन
टाइम पासवर्ड फॉर अकाउंट वेरिफिकेशन क्या
है
ये यह क्या है कांट एक्सेप्ट टेंपररी और
अनवेरीफाइड
तो अब क्या है भाई यह तो अनवेरीफाइड
है उसको मैं इधर साइड में करता हूं ठीक है
यहां
पे लेट्स चेक ओके दिस आर इट इज नॉट
एक्सेप्टिंग सो
लेट्स चेंज द ईमेल आईडी इंफो ईमेल आईडी
बिल्कुल सही है फिर भी ये एक्सेप्ट नहीं
कर रहे तो इसमें कुछ हम नहीं कर सकते वी
कांट डू एनीथिंग वी आर नॉट दे आर नॉट
एक्सेप्टिंग द एक्चुअल ईमेल आईडी राइट तो
एक्चुअल ईमेल आईडी ही नहीं कर पा रहे ये
क्या कर सकते
यार तो एक्चुअल ईमेल आईडी अगर यह नहीं कर
पा रहे हैं एक्सेप्ट नहीं करेंगे तो कैसे
काम चलेगा एक्चुअल ईमेल आईडी तो तो वी आर
मूविंग कोई दिक्कत नहीं है भाई कोई टेंशन
नहीं है कोई टेंशन नहीं टेंशन तो हम लेते
ही नहीं है भाई सही बोला ना टेंशन नहीं
लेना
है कोई और वेबसाइट देखेंगे साउ home.com
यह क्या है
भाई चलिए
साउंड कॉ
हां यह बढ़िया चीज है यह
कोई ई-कॉमर्स वेबसाइट है ग्रेट यह हमारे
काम आ सकते हैं शायद लेट्स
गो रियल ईमेल ही है भाई यहां पे तो यहां
पर साइन अप पर क्लिक करते हैं सर्च
फंक्शनल भी है तो ओबवियसली सर्च फंक्शनल
जब हो तो आप सिंपल सा एक सर्च क्लिक कर
सकते हैं जो नॉर्मल सर्च होता है वो आप कर
सकते हैं यहां पर इस तरीके से कंट्रोल य
करके यहां पे डि फ्रक्स देख सकते हैं कि
ये किस तरीके से हो रहा है ओबवियसली यहां
पे आप इनकोडिंग थोड़ा सा करके ट्राई आउट
कर सकते हैं इफ इट इज वर्किंग एंड बाकी और
भी बायपासेस अगर आपको करने हैं व ट्राई
आउट कर सकते हैं एंड यू कैन गो फॉर दैट
राइट वो कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है तो यहां पे
जो इनकोडिंग हुई है
ये ओके ठीक है तो चलिए यहां पे हम सिंपल
सा एक लॉगिन बना लेते हैं एक क्रिएट कर
लेते हैं वी आर गोइंग फॉर अ लॉगइन तो यहां
साइन अप पे क्लिक कर लेते हैं यहां पे एंड
यहां पे ईमेल एड्रेस मांग रहा है यह हमसे
तो हमने यहां पे ईमेल एड्रेस हम यहां पर
दे देते हैं टेंप मेल जो है वो जिंदाबाद
था जिंदाबाद है जिंदाबाद रहेगा तो यहां
पासवर्ड दे देते हैं
[संगीत]
अ हमने पासवर्ड दे
दिया यह कौन सा पासवर्ड है भाई कितने
पासवर्ड मांगता है
यह पता नहीं अच्छा यह साइन अप का पासवर्ड
है क्या ये सॉरी यहां पे पासवर्ड हमने दे
दिया ईमेल आई डाल दिया य पर हमने साइन अप
किया लेट्स सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग सो वी आर
साइंड अप ग्रेट बहुत अच्छी बात है डिड वी
गेट एनी ईमेल ऑन साइन
अप यह साइन अप हमने मिल हमें साइन अप मिल
गया है नहीं यह मुझे लगता कि दिस ऑन
वर्डप्रेस सही है य हमें कोई मेल तो नहीं
आया साइन अप का चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात है अब
हम क्या
करेंगे यहां हम चलते ऑर्डर्स पे इज देर
अकाउंट
फंक्शनैलिटी हां ये राइटर्स वाला है अब
देखो राइटर्स वाले में भी यहां पे चेक आउट
कर सकते हो तुम एक्सस हर एक फील्ड को जैसे
ये राइट राइट अस वाला जो है ना फील्ड तो
हम इस पे भी चेक आउट कर सकते हैं हमारी
एक्सएसएस जो हमारी फंक्शनैलिटी है वी कैन
जस्ट चेक आउट राइट तो हम यहां पे कॉपी कर
लेते हैं सेम अ लेट्स चेंज इट मैं यहां पे
इसके जगह पे डिफ्रॉक देता हूं एंड लेट्स
यूज दिस वन दिस एक्सस पेलोड वी आर गोइंग
टू यूज़ पेलोड यहां डाल देते हैं सेंड पर
क्लिक करते हैं इट इफ इट इज सेंडिंग
समथिंग वी हैव रिसीवड योर मैसेज थैंक्स
कुछ भी नहीं है ठीक है बढ़िया है मैसेज
इनको मिल चुका है बहुत अच्छी बात है यहां
पर अकाउंट सेटिंग प चलते हैं कर सकते हो
ट्राई कोई दिक्कत नहीं अकाउंट सेटिंग प चल
सकते हैं एंड अब यहां पे हम क्या कर सकते
हैं यहां पे देखो सेव करने का ये ऑप्शन आ
रहा है फर्स्ट नेम में फर्स्ट नेम में डाल
दीजिए अपना पेलो लास्ट नेम में पेलो डाल
दीजिए फोन नंबर आप ओरिजिनल फोन नंबर यूज
कर लीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है प् 91
ठीक है हमने डाल दिया मोबाइल नंबर डालने
की जरूरत नहीं कंपनी एड्रेस डाल एड्रेस डा
एड्रेस में भी वही डाल दिया सिटी में भी
वही डाल दिया पोस्टल जिप
में हमने यह डाल दिया कंट्री हमने इंडिया
सिलेक्ट कर लिया एंड ट्स इट यहां पर इतना
करना है एंड सेव प क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स
सी वट इ हैपनिंग ओके ओके कुछ हुआ
क्या नथिंग हैपनिंग कुछ हो नहीं रहा य प
ओबवियसली कुछ हो नहीं रहा यहां प भी डाल
देते हैं यहां भी डाल देते हैं कहीं भी
डाल दीजिए सेव कर लीजिए यहां पे सो या
नथिंग हैपनिंग हियर कुछ यहां पे हमें कुछ
मिल नहीं रहा बट यू कैन चेक आउट लाइक दिस
आप मतलब इस तरीके से चेक आउट कर सकते हैं
मैं आपको ये तरीके बता रहा हूं हर जगह पे
जहां भी पॉसिबल हो भाई डाल दो बस
सीधा-सीधा बात है तो मैं यहां पे ये
न्यूजलेटर है ना इस पे भी ट्राई आउट मार
लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है प्लीज एंटर वैलिड
ईमेल एड्रेस आ गया कोई टेंशन नहीं है
ऑर्डर इस्ट्री प जाओ कुछ अगर यहां पे
डालने का कुछ है तो यहां डाल दो नहीं है
कोई दिक्कत नहीं यहां पे पेज को ओपन कर
लेते हैं आप एक बार लेट्स ओपन द पेज दिस
पेज इज हियर लेट्स सी इफ वी आर सीइंग
समथिंग
अ डिटेल्स में यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं
है ओके सो यह हमारा पेज है साउ hm.com
इसको हम एज अ टारगेट भी अगेन हम ले सकते
हैं यहां पे एज अ टारगेट ओबवियसली हमें
टारगेट यहां इनस कोप हटाना
[संगीत]
पड़ेगा एंड यहां पे हम इसको रीलोड कर देते
हैं नाउ वल डू ल गेट द साउंड
[संगीत]
होम लेट्स चेक या ये अभी आना शुरू हुआ है
तो आई थिंक ऊपर आ जाएगा मेरे ख्याल से इट
विल बी कमिंग
हियर
या सो लेट्स फ्री लोड इट
अगेन ल सी बेवन भी तो भैया हमारे आ रहे
हैं हमारे साउंड साउंड ओएचएम साउंड ओएचएम
कहां गए भैया हमारे साउंड ओ
एचएम टा टा टा टा
थ डार्क ब्लैक में होगा आपका जो टारगेट
होगा बेसिकली तो जब भी आप चेक कर रहे हैं
डार्क ब्लैक के लिए चेक आउट
कीजिए सो इफ र समथिंग समथिंग समथिंग
समथिंग समथिंग
ओके
साउंड कुछ आ रहा है क्या
ओके यह थोड़ा सा लेट रेस्पों कर रहा है
हमारा बॉब शूट अ लिटिल बिट
लेट लेट्स वेट लेट्स वेट लिटिल बिट
लेट चलिए यह आप कर लीजिएगा बेसिकली यहां
पर थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा डिले हो रहा है
साउंड
ओके लेट्स डू वन
थिंग इंटरसेप्ट ऑन लेट्स रीलोड इट
लेट्स अ फॉरवर्ड ये
रहा सेंड टू स्पाइडर
स्पाइडर कर देते हैं यहां पर इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ
कर देते टारगेट कर देते
हैं
लेट्स स्पंग हो रही है क्या बिल्कुल हो
रही
है एंड दिस शुड
बी चलिए यहां पर एक बार कर देते
स्कैनर
यह रहा साउंड होम य यहां पर हमें हिस्ट्री
मिल रही है
पूरी स्पाइडरिंग इ गोइंग ऑन बट यहां पर
हमरे य प यार आख आ रहा है यार कहीं कुछ
दिख तो जा भाई कहीं तो दिख जा भाई कहीं हम
देख नहीं पा रहे शायद मे
बी दिख रहा है आपको टारगेट साउंड होम
साउंड एचएम करके जो है हमारा टारगेट एनी
वन कैन सी
कमाल की बात है दिख ही नहीं रहा या तो मिस
कर रहे हैं शायद मे बी मे
बी होगा इसी में कहीं ना कहीं छुपा हुआ
बैठा हुआ बट वी आर
मिसिंग हम उसको देख नहीं पा रहे
हैं
सो
इग्नोर ऊपर
था क ऊपर था
भाई बताओ कहां था ऊपर
भाई एंड यू कैन
यूटिलाइज टूल जो कि बेसिकली कटाना टूल से
आप यूआरएल गैदर कर सकते हैं अगर आप चाहते
किसी पर्टिकुलर यू आर
देखो इफ यू वांट टू गैदर अ कट लाइक गैदर
करना चाहते हैं आप कटाना टूल से आप यूज कर
सकते हैं सारे लिंक्स को गैदर कर सकते हैं
इफ यू वांट टू गेट द लिंक्स या वे बैक
यूआरएल भी आप यूज कर सकते हैं टू गेटिंग द
लिंक्स जो भी लिंक्स होते हैं जो भी एक
आपके टारगेट के अंदर ये रहा साउंड ओएचएम
ये मिल गया हमारा ऐड टू स्कोप कर देते हैं
यहां पे रिमूव फ्रॉम स्कोप ऑलरेडी है यहां
पे स्पाइडर हो ही रही है यहां पे एंड यहां
पे इन स्कोप आइटम्स कर देते हैं यहां पे
गलती हो गई मेरे को पहले ही कर देना चाहिए
था इन स्कोप वाला तो हमें वैसे भी मिल
जाता है ये साउंड ओएचएम वाला राइट क्योंकि
हमने ऑलरेडी स्कोप में इसको ऐड करके कर
दिया था ठीक है तो हमें ये मिल चुका है
साउंड ओएचएम वाला एंड यहां स्कोप में अगर
चलते हैं तो रोजर वायलेट जो है यह रिमूव
कर देते हैं यहां साउंड ओनली रहने देते
हैं तो यहां पे हमारा ऑलरेडी हो रहा है
यहां पे एंड हमें पैरामीटर्स मिल चुके हैं
200 वाले यहां पे सो साइन अप के साथ हमें
यहां एक पैरामीटर मिल रहा है जो कि
पासवर्ड यहां पे एंड ये यूजर नेम आपको दे
रहा है पास पाड को इसने कन्वर्ट कर दिया
है बहुत बढ़िया फीडबैक का यहां पे एक ईमेल
टेक्स्ट नेम आ रहा है देखो इसमें भी तुम
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो जैसे यहां पे ये
स्लश पैरामीटर पे मिल रहा है यहां पे नेम
एंड ये चीजें मिल रही है यहां पे य यहां
पे या क्विक सर्च क्वेरी यहां पे आ रहा है
आपका तो आप सिंपल सा फंडा है राइट क्लिक
करके सेंड टू इंट्रूडर आपने कर दिया यहां
पे एंड पोजीशंस पे चले गए यहां पे आपने
क्लियर कर दिया यहां पे आपने सर्च क्वेरी
जो है आपने इसको ऐसे करके ऐड कर दिया
पोजीशंस पी लोड प क्लिक लोड किया यहां पे
डेस्कटॉप पर चले आए हमारी जो पेलोड है
उसको उठाया य लोड किया एंड यहां पर हमने
स्टार्ट अटैक कर दिया अब जो है हमें कुछ
मिलता है तो वी विल गेट डाउन यर राइट 200
वाले स्टेटस चाहिए हमें बस ट्स इट
5392 5392 मिले य प हा अगर यह होने देते
हैं अटैक को 6000 इसके पहले इसके बाद इसके
पहले मैं आपको एक चीज और बता देता हूं
इसके लिए मैं
अपना मेरा
जो क्लाउड मशीन है मैं उसको स्टार्ट करता
हूं क्लाउड मशीन
में तो आपको भी क्लाउड में बग क्लाउड मशीन
यूज करनी है बग बाउंट की स्पीड को सुपर
फास्ट बनाने के लिए तो आप ओबवियसली डिजिटल
ओसन का जो है क्लाउड यूज कर सकते हैं
ड्रॉपलेट जिसको बोलते हैं उसमें आप अपने
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जो भी फेवरेट है यूज कर
सकते हैं मैं u2 स्टार्ट यूज कर रहा हूं
फिलहाल के लिए अपनी बक बाउंट जर्नी को
काफी ज्यादा फास्ट बना सकते हैं आप इसके
के थ्रू एंड अगर आप डिस्क्रिप्शन में इस
वीडियो के गए लिंक से डिस्क्रिप्शन में
आपको इस वीडियो के लिंक मिल जाएगी डिजिटल
ओसन का रेफरल लिंक उससे अगर आप आते हैं तो
आपको अभी फिलहाल के लिए दो महीने के लिए
60 दिनों के लिए $200 का आपको मिलेगा यहां
पे क्रेडिट जो कि मेरा आप देख रहे हैं
मेरे को भी मिला हुआ है ये काफी टाइम से
चल रहा है अभी भी तो आप तब तक उसको यूज कर
सकते हैं राइट तो यहां पे हम इसको यूज कर
रहे हैं एंड यहां पे हम एक टूल यूज कर
सकते हैं
कटाना कटाना गिट अप पे आपको मिल जाएगा इस
तरीके से कुछ मिल जाएगा इस तरह से कटाना
एंड इसको इंस्टॉल करने के लिए बहुत सिंपल
सा यहां पे आई थिंक गो गो का ये टूल है तो
आप गो इंस्टॉल करके कटाना यूज कर सकते हैं
चलिए हम अपने मशीन को स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं
फिलहाल के लिए मोबा एक्सटम के अंदर में वी
आर गोइंग टू कनेक्ट टू आवर
मशीन ठीक
है चलिए यहां पे हम यहां पे कनेक्ट
एग्जीक्यूट कर देते हैं एंड
लेट्स टाइप द
पासवर्ड अब इसका यूज क्या है मैं आपको
बताता हूं क्यों हम इसको यूज करने वाले
हैं कटाना हान एच करेंगे आप यहां पर तो
यहां पर आपको यूआरएल देनी है हान यू से
टारगेट जो यूआरएल है तो हम यहां पर देते
हैं कटाना हान यू एंड उसके बाद आप यूआरएल
दे दीजिए यहां पर आपको जैसे मेरा जो
टारगेट यूआरएल है वो है s home.com
ये वाला हमारा टारगेट है मान लो तो हम ये
यूआरएल टारगेट में दे देते हैं एंड यहां
पे हम एंटर करेंगे लेट्स सपोज तो ये जितने
भी इसके यूआरएल हैं उन सबको ये गदर करेगा
और पैरामीटर्स यूआरएल जो भी जो भी यूआरएल
है इस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट के लिए ये आपको
सारी यूआरएल जो है यहां पे गैदर करके दे
देगा एंड यहां से आप देख सकते हैं कि अगर
कोई पैरामीटर मिल रही है आपको बाय चांस वो
पैरामीटर के लिए आप जा सकते हैं बिल्कुल
चेक आउट कर सकते हैं ठीक है पैरामीटर के
लिए ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं यहां पर आप
इक्वल्स टू देके पैरामीटर को फिल्टर आउट
कर सकते हैं ग्रेप कर सकते हैं सब कुछ कर
सकते हो राइट
चलिए सो वी आर गेटिंग रिजल्ट
रिजल्ट्स गेटिंग द
रिजल्ट्स ठीक है व गेटिंग द
रिजल्ट्स
यस सारे आपको यूआरएल यहां पर फेच करके
देगा एंड इस यूआरएल में आप कहीं पर देख
सकते हैं अगर इफ यू आर गेटिंग सम
पैरामीटर्स पैरामीटराइज यूआरएल तो आप य उस
यूआरएल प एक्सस के पे लोट्स को डाल के एंड
ऑटोमेट कर सकते हैं आप अपने जोसे मैंने
आपको बताया वैसे आप काम कर सकते हैं ठीक
है सो सिंपल एज इट इज बहुत सिंपल सा है यह
देख सकते हैं सारे यूआरएल य आपको फेच करके
दे देगा तो यह कटाना टूल यूज कर सकते हैं
मोर मोरओवर यू कैन आल्सो गो एंड चेक वे
बैक
यूआरएल य भी आप यूज कर सकते हैं फेच ऑल
यूआरएल बेसिकली अ जो है आपको यूज करेगा वे
बैक यूआरएल जो है वेबैक मशीन से आपका
यूआरएल सच करेगा एंड आपको प्रोवाइड कर
देगा तो जैसे यहां पे आपको मिला स्टॉक इज
इक्वल टू ओनली ये आपको एक मिला पेज इवल ट
1 ये आपको एक अ पैरामीटर मिला यहां पे
लेआउट इज इक्वल टू बिग ग्रिड ये एक आपको
एक पैरामीटर मिल रहा है यहां पे टाइनी इज
इक्वल टू सिंकिंग ऑफ टाइनी ये तो नहीं ये
नहीं है यहां पे पेज इक्वल ट 1 ये मिला
आपको लेआउट इल लिस्ट दिस इज द पैरामीटर
राइट
एंड नीचे आ जाते हैं नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां
पे यहां पर नीचे आ जाते हैं नीचे आ जाते
हैं लेट्स चेक आउट लेट्स चेक आउट लेट्स
चेक आउट इ य आर गेटिंग सम मोर पैरामीटर्स
यहां
पे यहां पे यह वाला इ इक्वल टू इस तरीके
के आपको पैरामीटर्स मिल रहे है यहां
पे लेआउट का पैरामीटर यहां प आपको एक मिला
है यहां पे तो आपको इस तरीके से
पैरामीटर्स मिल जाएंगे देन यू कैन गो फॉर
द एक् समथिंग एक्सएसएस वाली आप जो पे
लोट्स है वो यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है और
हां एक चीज और आप सबको मैंने पहले ही
बताया हुआ है ऑलरेडी यहां पे आप वेब
सिक्योरिटी एकेडमी पे आपको आना है वेब
सिक्योरिटी अकेडमी को ओपन कर लेना है यहां
पे ऑल टॉपिक्स पे जाना है एंड आप सब पता
नहीं क्यों नहीं करते हैं मुझे नहीं पता
यहां पे क्लाइंट साइड में जाके एक्सएसएस
पे आने हैं एक्सस पे आके व्यू ऑल लैब्स पे
आना है एंड आपको ये सारे लैब्स को सॉल्व
करना है क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग के जो
लैब्स है इसको सॉल्व करना है देन यू हैव
टू गो टू द ट्राई हैक मी ट्राई हैक मी प
आपको आना
है अगर आपके पास पेड पेड नहीं है तो आप
ट्राई कीजिए पेड सब्सक्रिप्शन आपको सस्ते
में चीपर कहीं ना कहीं मिल ही जाएंगी आपको
मैं इतना बोल रहा हूं तो आप ट्राई कीजिए
एक्सेस सर्च कीजिए यहां पे क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग आपके मिल जाएगी यहां पे यह
जो लैब है इसको सॉल्व कीजिए यह बहुत
ज्यादा आपकी हेल्प करेगी ठीक है एक्स
एसएस यह वाली यह वाली लैब को पूरे कंप्लीट
कर लीजिए ये टास्क है जब भी आप कंप्लीट
करें तो आप बताइए जो भी आपने कंप्लीट किया
है और हमारे डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी कंपनी
को टैग कीजिए लिंकन प डालिए उसको एंड टैग
कीजिए ठीक है इससे हमारा जो है आपका
प्रोग्रेस भी पता चलेगा एंड आपकी एक टास्क
की तरह आप एक चीज भी कर रहे होते हैं ठीक
है ठीक है बहुत
बढ़िया सो देर इज अ
क्वेश्चन यस पैरा माइनर भी आप ट्राई कर
सकते हैं बिल्कुल बिल्कुल आकाश यू कैन गो
फॉर द पैरा माइर कोई दिक्कत नहीं जीएफ हां
हां बिल्कुल आप यूज कर सकते हैं मल्टीपल
टूल्स है देर आर मल्टीपल टूल्स यू कैन यूज
एनी टूल मैं तो बस एग्जांपल देता हूं आपके
लिए अ सर आई हैव फाउंड अ इंफो इन
प्रोग्राम व्हिच इज अबाउट
अ क्रेडिट नोट समथिंग लाइक और उसके अंदर
कंपनी की बिलिंग इंफो थी और उनका फोन नंबर
था क्या हम रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं अगर मास
नंबर ऑफ अ आपको मास में मिलता है ऐसा कोई
रिजल्ट कोई बहुत ज्यादा मिल जाता है तब
जाके आप यह सब काम करो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
बट अगर आपको एक दो मिल रहा है ऐसे कुछ
इंपैक्ट नहीं है तो आप रिपोर्ट करोगे तो
कोई फायदा नहीं है बट अगर इंपैक्टफुल लग
रहा है बहुत ज्यादा आपको सारे रिपोर्ट
सारी चीजें डिटेल्स मिल रही है तो आप
ओबवियसली डाटा इनफॉर्मेटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
डिस्क्लोजर में डाल सकते हो उसको ठीक
है ओके चलिए ठीक है ट्स इट ये तो मुझे
पहले आप लोग ये बता दीजिए जितने लोग भी
अभी प्रेजेंट है यहां पर लाइव स्ट्रीम में
जस्ट लेट मी नो गाइस आपको जो चीज अभी बताई
गई है जो भी चीजें अभी मैंने आपको बताई है
ठीक है आपको एक्सएसएस में इतना कुछ क्लियर
तो हुआ ना यह बताइए मुझे अभी जो किया जो
भी चीजें अभी आई है आपको बताई गई है वह
आपको क्लियर हुआ एंड आप एक्सेसेस के लिए
मैनुअली और ऑटोमेटेड वे जितने भी इनपुट
फील्ड्स है वहां डाल के साइन अप लॉग इन
कांटेक्ट अ एड्रेस अपडेट या आपके प्रोफाइल
अपडेट ईमेल एड्रेस जगह न्यूज़लेटर हर जगह
डाल के आप चेक आउट कर सकते हैं बब शूट का
यूज करके इंटर का ऑटोमेट कर सकते हैं एंड
आप अपने खुद के क्राफ्टेड एक्सेसेस के
पेलोड्स जनरेट कर सकते हैं जितना अच्छा
पेलोड होगा उतना अच्छा चांसेस होगा आपको
एक्सेसेस फाइंड करने के या मिलने के ठीक
है ये बात ध्यान रखिए राइट तो अभी तक
क्लियर तो है ना यह बताइए अभी तक क्लियर
है एंड मोस्ट प्रोबेबली हो सकता है इसका
एक और पार्ट आपके लिए आए जिसमें कि हम और
थोड़े से एडवांस थोड़ा सा कुछ हम डीप जाए
मे बी अगर आता है तो आपको नेक्स्ट क्लास
में मिल जाएगा ठीक है मे बी अगर नहीं आता
है तो नेक्स्ट टॉपिक हम करेंगे लेकिन अगर
आता है तो आपको नेक्स्ट क्लास में मिल
जाएगी तो अभी के
लिए बैक लॉक क्लियर कर
लीजिए जितना अभी बताया एक्सस के लिए आप
एक्सस हंट करना शुरू कर दीजिए क्योंकि
जितना आप हंट करेंगे यह बहुत बड़ी चीज है
हंट करते जाएंगे आपका वो एंड नहीं होने
वाला है तो इसको आप क्लियर कीजिए सभी लोग
प्लीज रिप्लाई कीजिए चैट में क्योंकि
जितने लोग हैं उतने लोग रिप्लाई करेंगे तो
मजा आता है है
ना ठीक है जितने आप ट्राई की जितना आप
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं प्रैक्टिस कर सकते
हैं जितना प्रैक्टिस कीजिएगा उतना आपके
लिए बेटर होगा मुझे यही पता है जितना
प्रैक्टिस नहीं कीजिएगा उतना ही आपको
प्रॉब्लम होगा समझने में ठीक है प्रैक्टिस
एंड प्रैक्टिस एक्सरसाइज फाइंड करना शुरू
कीजिए एंड हम अभी और भी चीजें लेकर आएंगे
बहुत कुछ अभी बाकी है मेरे दोस्त अभी तो
जस्ट शुरुआत हुई है सोचो अभी तो जस्ट
शुरुआत हुई है भाई है
ना नेक्स्ट क्लास में कितने दिन का गैप
चाहिए आपको बताइए आप लोग नेक्स्ट क्लास
में कितने दिन का गैप
चाहिए
बताइए नेक्स्ट क्लास में आप लोगों को
कितना दिन का गैप चाहिए लेट मी नो
गाइस दो
दिन एक दिन तीन
दिन तीन दिन तीन दिन दो
दिन ठीक है देखो गैप जब मिले तो उसको
प्रैक्टिस करना है उसमें प्रैक्टिस करना
है वो ऐसे छुट्टी छटी वाला काम नहीं करना
है छुट्टी मिल गई काम मस्ती से कर रहे हैं
नहीं प्रैक्टिस कीजिए नाना उस गैप में दो
दिन तीन दिन का आ रहा है मेरे पास ऑप्शन
तो चलिए ठीक है एंड जो पहले की क्लासेस है
मैं आप सबसे एक रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा आप अगर
पहले की क्लासेस आपने नहीं करी है अटेंड
तो इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट टू डू द क्लासेस जो
भी प्रीवियस क्लासेस हुई है उसको कंप्लीट
कीजिए कैसे भी करके आज 19 हो गया अगले
क्लास में 20वां लेक्चर हो जाएगा भाई 20
समझ रहे हो कुछ एक लेक्चर का एवरेज
ड्यूरेशन दो घंटे का है समझ 40 आवर्स की
आपकी हो चुकी है पूरी कोर्स फ्री में भी
इतने आवर्स का कोर्स आपको नहीं मिलता
जल्दी समझ में आ रहा है बैकलॉग मींस जो
पहले की वीडियोस है उसको कवर कीजिए ठीक है
ठीक
है ओके जस्ट कंप्लीट ओके बैकलॉग को क्लियर
कीजिए एंड आज के क्लास के लिए बस इतना ही
याद रखिएगा ये हमारा डेनिक्स का पेज है
इसको जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा लिंकन पे टैग
कीजिएगा हमें जो भी आप अपडेट जो भी चीजें
कीजिएगा एंड वी विल
अ कीप ब्रिंगिंग सच ऑसम कंटेंट्स फॉर यू
ऑल ठीक है ओके तो कंप्लीट कर ली जिनका छूट
गया ओके तो धन्यवाद थैंक यू वेरी मच आप
सबका फॉर जॉइनिंग द लाइव सेशन थैंक यू सो
मच गाइस एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
इस क्लास के लिए बस इतना ही एंड हैव अ गुड
नाइट टाटा बाय बाय टेक केयर चलिए गुड नाइट
बोल दीजिए सभी लोग एक बार और चलते हैं
बाय